members please take your seats
members take your seats please
no you can't see anything over there
members take their seats
members please take your seats
good morning
okay thank you
[Music]
so
like
okay
i got
yeah
so
[Music]
yeah know
oh
hi mark
[Music]
members take their seats
you
oh yeah
because
members of the house
if you could please make sure that
you're checking your clickers
make sure that your name is on the back
representative mclean
has
his clicker was taken by somebody else
so please
make sure that you are checking
the names on the back of your clicker
make sure it's you thank you
members take their seats
we're going to start
the clerk has three quick announcements
thank you mr speaker just a couple of
reminders please
if you are seated
in the unmasked section
please remain in the unmasked section
and if you need to use the restrooms
they are available outside the doors if
you are in the math section please use
the mass section bathrooms thank you
parking validation remember that the
stamps are at the two party tables
lastly if you are leaving early please
inform me either via text or email that
you're leaving so we can excuse your
votes
also
you can either leave your clickers at
your seats or at the tables in the rear
thank you
before before i officially start
everybody's have been asking what's
going to happen tomorrow
we've still got a number of bills to go
through
i think we'll have to make that
determination maybe about one o'clock or
1 30 or something of that nature as to
what's going to happen
but it looks like
unless we're do our due diligence we're
not going to get through all the bills
today which means we will be coming back
here tomorrow
we we're looking at the weather
from all indications it looks like we're
in the area of two to four inches i know
that doesn't apply to everybody
uh but we'll have to uh
unfortunately we'll just have to play it
by ear and see how the day goes and see
what the weather forecasts are
and
we'll
hopefully get through as much as we can
today and maybe not have to come back
tomorrow
the house has come to order the chair
recognizes the member from auburn
representative osborne who moves at the
house adjourned from the session of
january 5th 2022 are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
the house will tend to a prayer by
hell's chaplain rev bob stewart pastor
of saint paul's united methodist church
in manchester
good morning
this morning i'd like to share
in part
excuse me a prayer written by reverend
marcy shermeta
as the dawn breaks on a new year
let us give thanks for all that we hold
dear
our health
our family and our friends
let us release our grudges
our anger and our pains
for these are nothing but binding chains
let us live each day
in the most loving ways
the god-conscious way
let us serve all who are in need
regardless of race color or creed
let us keep god of our own understanding
in our hearts
and to chant god's name each day
let us lead the world from darkness to
light
from falsehood to truth
and from wrong to right
let us remember that we are all one
embracing all
discriminating against none
may our year be filled with peace
prosperity and love
may god's blessing shower upon us and
bestow upon each of us a bright healthy
and peaceful new year
o god
guide the leaders that are gathered here
today
that in turn they may guide us also into
your ways
bind us together by your love
and cause us to know ourselves to be a
people called out of darkness into your
marvelous light
guide our discussions in love and
respect for you
and for each other
may we hear your voice and feel your
presence
through the words spoken aloud
this day
lead and guide us oh god
lead us in
and through
your love
amen
the chair recognizes the member from
deerfield representative kevin verville
who will lead us in the pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
please remain standing for the plane of
our national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend to request for
leaves of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives aldrich juaras cushing
dauntonville fenton litchfield
pantalakis richards ruyard spang the day
important business representatives birch
cornell cody ebel fargo macbeth moran
milor salloway southworth
the day illness in the family
representatives elliott sandler
safrikidus tanner
these leaves of absence will be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will now attempt at the
continuation of the regular calendar
beginning with house bill 238 from the
criminal justice committee
committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 238 an act
prohibiting provocations based on a
witness's actual perceived gender gender
identity gender expression or sexual
orientation from being used as a defense
in manslaughter cases
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass senator casey conley
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate senator gary
harper and the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
abramson to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i rise
against the ought to pass motion on
house bill 238
victims in these cases can be gay or
straight and the accused can be gay or
straight
while the famous gay panic defense
rarely works in court
it has sometimes been used along with
other defenses to try to convince juries
to select a lesser includer offense of
manslaughter instead much of the reason
why we have a trial by jury is to allow
you
when facing life in prison
to allow you to argue why your actions
may have been criminal but were not so
evil as to justify life in prison
i am probably the only member of this
general court who has actually had to
face life in prison for a justifiable
legally justifiable act
in my case the evidence showed that my
actions were completely justified
legally
for others
who've attacked injured or even killed
another the need to present the whole
story the entire case warts and all to a
jury of their peers is truly a matter of
life and death
denying the accused a due process right
before a jury of their peers to try to
humanize or mitigate their actions
violates a fundamental due process right
that is older than this country itself
the article 15 right under our new
hampshire constitution quote to be fully
heard in his defense by himself and
council unquote
under separation of powers our role is
to protect rights not to erode them
we have never knowingly taken away a due
process right and this bill would be a
dangerous precedent and a major
overreach on the part of the general
court but we may not regard the gay
panic defense as quote objectively
reasonable unquote the notion of a judge
telling a man accused that he cannot
speak in his own defense or that the
facts must be kept out only for
political reasons is an ominous one red
button
the chair recognizes representative
abbott to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of the committee's recommendation of
ought to pass
manslaughter
is defined as when a person causes a
death of another while under the
influence of extreme mental or emotional
disturbance
caused by extreme
provocation by
which would otherwise constitute murder
this bill does not carve out a special
class for any any group of individuals
the bill is written would apply
to the lgbtq plus community as well as
straight individuals
but what would be happening
someone who is charged with murder would
be claiming that they were provoked
to commit the act of murder based on
someone's sexuality
such a defense i don't believe
is as reasonable to be raised in today's
society
realistically what this amounts to is a
mitigation defense in defenses to crimes
including murder are can be legally
defined for example
one cannot claim duress as a defense to
commit the act of murder
when this defense is raised
the defendant raising it has already
conceded that they they killed someone
and they're simply trying to reduce
their charge from murder
to manslaughter
essentially
the killer is claiming
that they should receive a lesser
sentence because they murdered someone
because of the victim's sexuality gender
or gender identity
and what makes it manslaughter was the
fact of that of how that person lives
their life
if the victim's sexuality gender or
gender identity serves as the motivation
to commit murder
it is it should not be acceptable
that that would actually lesser the
sentence
it actually serves as a motivation for
the crime they committed
to make matters worse while this would
play out in a courtroom
the victim's family who had a family
member murdered
would be sitting in the courtroom
listening
to to the killer attempt to mitigate
their egregious behavior by presenting
what i would classify as otherwise a
hate speech
for that reason i don't believe that
this defense would ever work in the
courtroom in new hampshire
and for that reason we should not allow
it to be raised
therefore
please join me in pushing the green
button
and support hard to pass thank you
question before us is the majority
report of how to pass on house bill 238
are you ready for the question
mr mr speaker
representative byrd has requested a roll
call
is that sufficiently seconded mr speaker
i'm sorry i didn't just a minute
is is that sufficiently second it is
sufficiently seconded for what reason
remember rise uh it's probably too late
now i wanted to make a motion to table
it is it is too late we are in the
voting mode right now
i put the question out
so
roko
they're on
just to be clear when you say
house will come to order the chair
recognizes representative sylvia for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker very simply
if i believe our constitution
provides
that every defendant
have a right
to produce
any
defense
in our
due process requires such
but i then press
the red button
the chair recognizes
the chair recognizes representative
conley for a parliamentary degree
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that around the country this
discriminatory gay panic defense is used
successfully to excuse the murder of
members of the lgp btq plus community
and if i know that this bill does not
dismiss traditional self-defense claims
and does not deny existing due process
defense
and if i further know that our state
values personal freedom and that our
state ranks very high in projecting
protecting
lgbtq plus rights if i know all this
would i then press the green button to
pass hb 238 thank you
the question is on house bill 238 the
majority report of ought to pass
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative alicea
representative ankerberg
representative heir
representative cross
try again
so
here
i got you
representative ankerberg sorry
foreign
nope
representative van houten are you here
today
she's not
representative sodi are you here
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
else will attend to the state of the
vote
223 quoting a 118 voting committee
reports adopted
majority of criminal committee on
criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 579 an
actor requiring notice to the public
before immigration checkpoints are
conducted
consider the same report the same with
the following amendment recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment it's a little harriet goth
right for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator chris
true for the minority of the committee
committee amendment is
2201 h
printed in house record 48 page 98. are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have an amendment is adopted
the question before us is the ought to
pass with amendment on house bill 579
are you ready for the question
[Music]
representative byrd has requested a roll
call as that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
call
now
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative muse
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the federal
immigration checkpoints can represent a
significant intrusion on civil liberties
cause delays for local residents and
provoke anxiety among new citizens and
legal immigrants that can be alleviated
with a simple public notice then would i
press the green button and say yes to hb
579 thank you
the question is on
majority
committee report
on house bill 579
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative levitt are you here today
is representative here
it's represented snow here
represent porter
representative prudhomme o'brien
representative nunning wong
lachman
representative lundgren
representative maggiore
represent manjaputi
representative mann
john mann
represent marston
can you try representative
try
okay
representative frost
represent cohen
try pushing it
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
254 voting yay 85 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 598.
it's getting awful loud in here
if you're near a microphone and you're
having a conversation
then it doesn't help it amplifies the
noise
so please take that into consideration
also
an act relative to the portion of the
minimum sentence to be served to be
eligible for parole we consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution
result that is inexpedient to legislate
senator dick marston from the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator linda harriet garth wright for
the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
harriet garth wright to speak against
the committee report
thank you thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to hb 598 itl
hb 598 is not a repeal
however it's a strategic sense it's
truth and sentence
reform hb 598 reforms new hampshire's
antiquated and extreme truth in
sentencing policy and works as a
mechanism to undo many years of
ineffective expensive and harmful
policies that have contributed to mass
incarceration and racial disparities in
the criminal legal system here in new
hampshire
the 1980s saw a wave of so-called get
tough on crime policies
these included mandatory minimums three
strike laws and a policy known as truth
and sentencing
which required that people serve a
certain percentage of their minimum
sentence before being eligible for
parole
these 1980 policies were extreme
and we've spent the past few decades
walking them back
the committee passed legislation already
this section to remove some of the
remaining mandatory minimums that we
still have on the books here in new
hampshire
this legislation would
reform our antiquated and extreme truth
and sentencing policies
different states adopted different
versions of truth and sentencing
with new hampshire adopting the most
extreme option one hundred percent
while some states require people to
serve seventy or eighty percent and in
some cases sixty percent
this requirement has prevented new
hampshire from being able to grant time
off for good behavior
meaning for decades we have lacked the
ability to incentivize rehabilitation a
central purpose for incarceration
after punishment
moreover truth and sentencing have
resulted in people spending more time in
prison
meaning a higher price tag for taxpayers
who must pay for every day someone
spends in prison
with one year in prison costing
taxpayers roughly forty thousand dollars
truth incenting is expensive extreme and
outdated
many other states have repealed or
amended their truth and sentencing laws
including those states that have fewer
extreme versions to begin with
the 1980s notion that if we were just
extreme enough in our punishment
we could deter or even
in crime has been consistently disproven
extreme sentencing causes far more harm
than good
the goal of incarceration should be
punishment rehabilitation
and we need to amend our policies
accordingly
hb 598 would amend our truth and
sentencing law to require that people
serve 50 percent of their minimum before
being eligible for parole
being eligible for parole does not mean
that a person will automatically be
paroled
it means they can apply
and the parole board will make a
determination on a case-by-case basis
so
that's the other option whereas today
it's
all cases are treated pretty much the
same and there's no incentive incentive
to
do better or or work on your
incarceration or your rehabilitation
so this bill also starts with you're not
eligible to go before the parole board
if you have your minimum is less than
five
years
so thank you mr speaker and i ask that
everyone press the red button
to vote against the bill
the chair recognizes representative
klein knight
thank you mr speaker
parole systems were designed to give
every incarcerated individual the
opportunity to earn release and have a
fair transparent process for deciding
whether or not they are granted this
release
over the years many states have reformed
the policies that would ensure
consistency and fairness and how they
identify those who should receive parole
when those individuals should be up for
another review for parole and what
parole conditions the individual must
follow
if they even were to be released
remember people we are simply talking
about the right to a hearing
this bill has been worked on by many
professional stakeholders criminal
criminal justice lawyers and our very
own criminal justice chair who was also
a sponsor on this bill
in good faith both sides of the aisle
came together to work on making this
process more just and fair we did this
because some of our laws have not been
updated in decades
we know this we recognize our
responsibility and role as legislators
to update outdated laws to protect our
citizens ensuring everyone is treated
the same in a system that was designed
to inspire hope and trust in the justice
system
by not updating these laws they do not
fit the times and we erode the
principles that allow our people to
trust that they will be treated fairly
not only was this a bipartisan bill it
was our last bill hearing for the year
and the only one we had that day
we met at 10 am to listen to an
amendment that would address concerns
held by all of us everyone was notified
of the amendment transparency had never
been in question since this bill had
been worked on for months by both
parties
the hearing only consisted of two people
testifying
one of which
was speaking was a parole board member
upon asking them a series of questions
on how the parole system works we
learned several very important pieces of
information
number one
new hampshire is the only state in the
united states of america that requires
an inmate to serve 100 of their minimum
sentence before being eligible for a
parole hearing again this is just a
right to a hearing
number two
we learned that in order to be eligible
for parole inmates must complete a
number of hours participating in classes
and rehabilitation activities to even
reach a chance at a hearing
number three and this one was a kicker
the parole member on record informed us
that an inmate cannot even start classes
or other forms of rehabilitation
until a judge signs off on this request
can i be heard please
[Music]
it's getting a little noisy again
member does have a right to speak
remember may continue
the parole board member on record
informed us that an inmate cannot even
start classes or other forms of
rehabilitation until a judge signs off
on this request
they went on to say that not only are
there hundreds of backlogged cases there
would not be enough parole board members
to have these hearings proving that our
prisoners couldn't even start the parole
in good behavior rehabilitation programs
even if they wanted to
so not only are we denying people the
right to a hearing we are now denying
them the right to start the
rehabilitation process
what had once been a bipartisan lift a
group effort to do honest work and fix a
broken system for our people now divided
us because of staffing issues
in what world do you think it is
justifiable to deny someone the right to
a fair shake and strip them of their due
process because there are simply not
enough staff
a bipartisan bill that would have
updated an old law bringing us up to the
standards of all other 50 states a bill
that would simply offer a person the
right to a hearing due process is not a
partisan issue it affects us all the
justice system was designed to uphold
fairness and equality that we all have a
right to because without that fairness
what is the point
that day my colleagues voted to strip
the citizens of their due process rights
because of staffing issues if you feel
that it is justifiable to keep a human
being locked up behind bars taking years
of their life away from them affecting
their families communities without the
right to fair due process mr speaker
what may reason to the member rise
parliamentary inquiry
when our colleagues can only do a point
of order at this point okay opponent of
water then please what is your point of
voter when our colleague says the word
you is she speaking about all of us in
the room or is she talking to you
directly mr speaker i'm confused
globally thank you for your question
it wasn't a question
i
honestly representative i am not sure
who she was addressing
i would assume the members
in the chamber right now
mr speaker
further question
further point of
water
it sounds to me that she's painting her
colleagues on the criminal justice
committee in an unfavorable light is is
that what it sounds like to you
point of order mr speaker i'm feeling
insinuated wait wait
just a minute
i i cannot
answer that question one way or the
other
who was she who was she was addressing
or wasn't addressing
the member may continue
for what reason does the member rise
question question of the speaker mr
speaker
only a point of order right now
representative
a question does not stop another member
in debate i'm sorry
was that permission a question yeah is
is
the question that i have is
the word you is often a rhetorical
uh is it not possible that we all every
single one of us use you as a rhetorical
device regularly in this chamber without
being interrupted in our speech
thank you
the point
the house will come to order
the member may continue
i'm sorry that i if i offended anybody
just continue representative
if you feel that it is justifiable to
keep a human being locked up behind bars
taking years of their life away from
them affecting their families and
communities without the right to fair
due process because we need to hire more
people than fine kill this bill but if
you think that not having enough parole
members is an egregious excuse to keep
people incarcerated and affects the
fairness of our justice system and that
it is not the responsibility nor the
fault of someone that is behind bars for
the government's hiring process then
will you support overturning the itl and
stand up for due process as is our duty
as elected officials
the chair recognizes representative roy
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
the criminal justice committee having
heard testimony from the parole board
the aclu and various witnesses
actually it came down that it was a
bipartisan issue and we agree that some
change is necessary
what my colleague previously said
regarding
safety in the country and the reason we
have these sentencing laws
is the reason that new hampshire is the
safest state in the country
having said that we do agree that some
work is needed to be done on the
sentencing laws however the other side's
proposal
of 50 percent
only having to serve 50
of the minimum sentence
was way beyond what we were willing to
work for
i feel that much work is done needed to
be done on this issue
with regard to the comments repeatedly
made about due process
due process was granted at a trial where
they were judged by a jury of their
peers
in the appellate process is available to
all inmates
unless we the legislature
set a process for them to follow due
process has been followed
so i ask you to join me in voting to
support the itl in recommendation of the
committee thank you
question before us in house bill 598 is
the majority report of inexpediential
legislate
are you ready for the question
the vision has been requested
the division has been requested members
will take their seats
division
[Music]
so
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
conley for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know new hampshire is the only state
where inmates must serve 100 percent
of their minimum sentence
and if i further know that the new
hampshire prison population increased
tenfold
since
the truth and sentencing law took effect
in the early 1980s
and finally mr speaker if i know that hb
would give inmates a real incentive
to improve their lives in prison to
rehabilitate themselves so that they
could qualify for parole
if i know all that would i press the red
button to defeat this motion so another
one could be made thank you
the chair recognizes representative
abdus for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
i'm now here at c3
if i know that hb 598
would retroactively reduce sentences
that includes
sentences that were part of a plea
agreement with the victims of a violent
crimes blessing
if i know that that would amount to an
injustice to victims of violent crimes
but i go ahead and push that green
button support the committee's
recommendation about of indicating to
legislate
thank you
the question is on
hb 598 the majority report have been
expedient to legislate this a division
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
represent dodge
representative air
representative herbert
represent blundgren
we don't have
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
181 voting yay 171 voting no committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety which was
referred house bill 620 fn local an act
requiring law enforcement agencies to
gather and analyze certain demographic
information having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate is an a david testament for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass it's in our brain newman for the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative muse
to
speak against the committee report
mr speaker
may i make a motion at the table
you may
motion to table
the motion before us
is to table
are we going to do
parliamentary inquiries or just
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
620 is laid on the table
majority committee on criminal justice
and public safety which was referred
house bill 629 fn
neck relative to the home cultivation of
cannabis plants in the possession of
certain cannabis infused products having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study presented
scott wallace for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate casey conley from the
minority of the committee
for what remembered as a purpose right i
mean remember does purpose does the
member rise
thank you mr speaker
i'm making a motion to table
the motion is in order
a
question
a division has been requested
members will take their seats
division
so
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 629
house will come to water
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker
if i know
that nearly 80 percent of new
hampshirites support re-legalization of
marijuana
although this is a more of a compromised
bill if i know
that this is one of the simplest bills
before us on marijuana policy
and if i also know that there's a very
strong chance
that this will be
an overturned itl bill and the number of
people have signed up to speak on this
would i now press the red button
chair recognizing representative abbott
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that there are several
uh bills that have been filed this this
term that address
canvas and mr speaker if i know that
there's been a lot of compromises and
discussions made that is part of a lot
bigger picture and
this this particular bill will
contradict some of the provisions of
other bills
would i go ahead and push that green
button support the motion of the table
the question before us is on house bill
629 the tabling motion
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent perezni
represent boards
represent me and you're all set
yes
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
144 voting a 210 voting nay 144 voting a
210 voting nay the motion to table fails
now we're now back to the
majority report of interim study chair
recognizes representative abramson
to speak against the committee report
thank you
mr speaker i rise to speak against the
majority report of interim study on
house bill 629 fn home cultivation of
cannabis
this simple bill
would allow inhabitants to grow up to
six plants and share with those over 21
age 21 in your own home
it is not
and never has been the job of government
to try to protect you from hurting
yourself
and outside of 1950s b horror movies it
has never been the job of government to
protect you from a plant
congress has voted to step up the war on
drugs many times since president lyndon
johnson
announced
i can barely hear myself
mr speaker can we please
have
it quiet in the chamber the member has a
right to be heard
if you're going to leave and go out the
hallway please do it quietly
the longer it takes
for us to get through these bills the
longer we're going to be here
and the longer we're going to have to
come in tomorrow
so i ask everyone to please respect the
rights of the member speaking
thank you mr speaker
congress has voted to step up the war on
drugs which is essentially a war on
marijuana users many times since
president lyndon johnson announced the
experiment on national television in
1967 resulting in an increase in crime
and an expansion of the illegal black
market drug traffic each time which is
what we're trying to combat with this
bill
members should not try to satisfy their
cravings to control others by
maintaining outdated laws that no longer
enjoy public support
why interim study such a simple bill
just pass it and be done with it please
press the red button
chair recognizes representative warden
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker over here on
microphone c3
as we've done
many times in the past years we saw
yesterday that this body is in favor of
restoring the right of possessing a
plant product for personal use
i believe we got caught up yesterday on
the question of taxes and additional
bureaucracy
but this bill at hand
strips out those needless regulations it
is a straightforward common sense bill
to treat adults like adults there is no
taxation involved which should please my
friends on this side of the room who
don't like taxes
this is truly a bipartisan issue with
strong and wide support from granite
staters
the war on cannabis is a war on people
those people are our neighbors and our
constituents let's do the right thing
this morning and expand freedom for the
people of new hampshire i implore my
colleagues to vote no on this motion so
that another motion can be brought
forward thank you
chair recognizes representative conley
to speak against committee report
thank you mr speaker i'll keep this
brief we've already covered this issue
pretty well this is a clear simple bill
it would legalize cannabis for adults 21
and older and it's essentially a
possession bill
no retail sales at all in this bill
and i'll just leave it at that this is a
bill that has passed this body two years
ago with a veto proof margin it does not
need more study
i ask that we overturn the committee
report so another could be made thank
you
chair recognizes representative abbas to
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation of interim study
and
the reason why i believe this bill
will benefit from further studying by
the committee is that as i said several
times yesterday and i'll repeat myself
today
that there are several bills that bills
that even have not even had a public
hearing
that
involve issues related to cannabis
including restrictions on the the
possession limits
and
there needs to be unification amongst
those policies uh if we were to pass
this bill we would be passing several
bills that all have a different
possession amount
and we need to be unified on that on
this subject if we're going to put
anything forward
my colleague who just spoke is a
co-sponsor of the bill that we have and
we have right now in the committee of
the criminal justice public safety
committee that we i believe
will pass this body i'm hoping it passes
with the veto proof majority as well
but in order for us to put forward the
best bill possible we cannot just keep
passing
all these bills that have inconsistent
possession limits it creates confusion
amongst uh it would create confusion
amongst the public and it sends mixed
messages messages on the on the exact
policy we want to put forward
so
please support me in supporting the
committee's recommendation for interim
study and please push that green button
thank you
question before us is the
majority report of interim study on
house bill 629
division has been requested
members will take their seats
division
so
the house will come to water
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker mr speaker if i know that
that motions for interim study are done
to hold on to a bill not to kill a bill
and if i know that this is one of the
simplest bills in front of this body
simply legalizing or re-legalizing
personal growing and sharing within your
own home among adults over 21 and if i
know that all of the issues that need to
be resolved have already been resolved
through the course of the debate and
public hearings would i now press the
red button
the chair recognizes representative
abbas for parliamentary inquiry
you mr speaker i would like to wave off
the pi
the question before us is on house bill
629 the majority report of interim study
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative all
chiller
representative bixby
representative levesque
representative john mcdonald
representative howard
representative bill nelson
representative perez
representative yakubovic
is it working
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
122 voting a 231 vote in a
the committee report of interim study
fails
mr speaker
on my microphone c3
yes for motion
recognize yourself
mark warden c3 imove ought to pass
on hb629
okay the motion is ought to pass on
house bill 629 are you ready for the
question
[Music]
a railroad call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
division
you're still like
the house will come to water
the question is on house bill 629
the report of the report of ought to
pass this is the division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if your approach will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative callum
representative levesque here today
representative michelier
representative yakubovic
i saw him
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
household 10 to the state of the vote
241 voting
241 voting 813 vote in a
committee report of what a pass is
adopted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 632 enact banning a
sentence of life imprisonment without
parole for a juvenile convicted of
homicide having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that as in expedient
to legislate senator dave testament for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate casey conley from the
minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
conley to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker colleagues i rise
again
to speak against the committee
recommendation this time for hb 632 this
bill would eliminate the sentence of
life without parole for juvenile
offenders life without parole is the
maximum sentence any judge could issue
it's reserved for the worst offenders
who commit the most awful violent
heinous crimes there's no disputing that
and there's no getting around that point
but we know the juvenile offenders are
different from adults
we know that human brains are still
developing
and still maturing until we turn 25.
intense emotions impulse control anger
management these are things we learn as
we age
these are also factors that can
influence a child's thinking or lack
thereof before they commit a terrible
it's also worth considering the purpose
of prison within the criminal justice
system
yes part of it is about punishment
but it is also about rehabilitation
for a juvenile sentenced to life without
parole there is no opportunity for
rehabilitation
for a crime they committed as a child
this punishment says that the child is
irredeemable
i don't believe that
finally i will note that ending the
sentence of life without parole for
juvenile offenders does not guarantee
any offender will get out it only
guarantees they will have a chance at
some point to go before a parole board
this kind of change would not be
groundbreaking for our state 25 states
plus washington d.c have abolished this
sentence
new hampshire should join these states
and we can by overturning the committee
recommendation and passing this bill so
i would ask you again to overturn the
committee report so another motion could
be made thank you
mr speaker
back in c3
yes sir can i ask the representative a
question please does the member yield to
a question
sure remember yields you may inquire
thank you thank you mr speaker thank you
representative
so if i understand this correctly a 15
or 16 year old who's
convicted of murder
could still face 20 or 25 years in jail
let's face it to a 15 year old is a
lifetime
if this bill would pass
and
it just made bans that they can't go
forever without parole is that correct
representative you addressed the
situation well thank you
the chair recognizes representative roy
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
the committee after hearing testimony
came to the conclusion that this bill
should be inexpedient to legislate
what is
not well known is that life in prison
for juveniles mandatory life unlike for
adults is already illegal the united
supreme united states supreme court has
ruled that mandatory life for juveniles
is illegal and therefore it's not
imposed it is left up to a judge to
decide after hearing the facts weighing
the evidence
hearing from the victims and the
defendant to make the decision whether
or not to sentence a juvenile to life in
prison
in making that decision the judge takes
into account the age of the offender
we cannot do that we cannot be at every
trial we cannot hear all the facts of
the trial we do not know the victims if
a juvenile 17 years old commits murder
and the judge finds the character of the
crime so heinous he may indeed sentence
into life without parole
juveniles
nowadays
many of them have extensive records by
the time they already become adults and
have proven themselves to be ill-fitted
for rehabilitation
another aspect
of the criminal justice and besides
punishment and rehabilitation is
protecting the public protecting the
public from dangerous offenders
it has left the judge to decide
in his best left in in his hands or her
hands after hearing all the facts of
each case knowing whether or not someone
is worthy of rehabilitation or not
i would ask you to support the
committee's recommendation of any
expedient to legislate and leave this in
the hands of the judiciary where it
belongs thank you
question before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 632
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
division vote
division
good
you guys
the question before us is
in
expedient to legislate on house bill 632
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative alicea
representative cushman
representative ham
representative norgren
representative o'brien
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
181 voting 174 voting nay committee
report is adopted
mr speaker
uh 1a representative sampson 1a
yes representative uh i'd like to uh
make a motion
to rehear
uh to reconsider uh our
vote on
629 the cannabis bill and i encourage
everyone to vote against
uh
re um okay reconsideration you're making
a motion to reconsideration
on 6 29.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the nays have it
reconsideration is not accepted
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety which was
referred senate bill 92 fn an act
relative to increasing the penalty for
criminal mischief the release of a
defendant pending trial and requiring
law enforcement candidate background
checks having considered the same report
the same with the following amendment
and recommendation the bill ought to
pass with amendment
majority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative john bourdinet for the
minority of the committee
what member reason does it memorized
thank you mr speaker
i wish to make a motion to table senate
bill 92
the motion is in order
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and senate bill 92 is
laid on the table
mr speaker
yes oh
i need to read it first representative
thank you
majority committee on education to which
was referred house bill 20 fna local
enact establishing the richard dick
hinch education freedom account program
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill will be referred for interim study
senator glenn cordelli for the majority
of the committee the minority of the
committee having considered the same and
being unable to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator david bruno from the
minority of the committee
what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i'd like to move
the hb to honey be laid on the table
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is to lay hb 20 on the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
hb 20 is laid on the table
majority of committee on education to
which was referred house bill 136 a now
requiring schools to update documents
and software to include the option of
identifying a student as non-binary
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative alicia leakers
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative stephen woodcock for
the minority of the committee
mr speaker
i'd like to make a motion
or what is the motion i would like to
move that hb 136 be late on the table
the motion is
in order
the motion before us is that house bill
136 be laid on the table
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this is a division
vote
division
[Music]
what talk is
this will be a division vote on house
bill
this will be a division vote in house
bill 136 the motion is to lay on the
table
the chair recognizes representative
woodcock for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know this bill
is simply a
change on a computer program
if i know this bill cost the state
nothing
if i know this bill helps parents of
marginalized students i would ask you to
vote no on lay on the table so may be
able to debate to debate this bill after
thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative cordelli
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that contrary to
the minority report
the department of education is not
required under this legislation to make
any change
and if i know that only local districts
are to make the requested changes but
they can make those changes without this
legislation
and if i know that the basic question we
have to ask is legislation needed and
the answer to this for this bill is no
would i now press the green button
the question is on the tabling motion on
house bill 136
it's a division vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative abramson
representative bernardi
represent thank you representative
espidio
representative diane kelly
representative klose
representative stavis
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
household 10 to the state of the vote
194 voting a 163 voting a the motion to
table
passes kim
okay um
just so everybody knows
we're gonna be alternating speakers
during the course of the day so nobody
gets
too burnt out for the uh
standing up here for eight nine hours
so
representative rice
[Applause]
the house will be in order
good morning friends
okay
the committee on education to which was
referred hb 214 an act relative to
school building aid grants having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
amendment number 2225h
printed in house record 48 pages 87
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it
now we're on to ought to pass with
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
oppose nay
commotion passes
look at me go
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred hb 255
and act relative to limited liability
for institutions of higher education and
businesses having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass as amended
amendment number
nope
scooch right on to the second page the
minority of the committee on education
to which was referred hb 255
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
that the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative
representative david luno for the
minority of the committee madam speaker
i'd like to make a motion please what is
your motion i'd like to lay 255 on the
table
would you like to speak to your motion
oh never mind
i'm learning are you ready for the
question i will do a pi
did did you want to
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
who requested the roll call
representative
cushman
and it is sufficiently seconded members
will take their seats
roll call
okay
do i have to say anything else
this is a roll call vote the members
should be taking their seats
the motion on the is to lay
hb 255 on the table representative
blasek is recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you madam speaker if i
know that the primary function of
government is to protect individual
rights from infringement and if i know
that the number one issue i hear from my
constituents are about medical mandates
then i would press the red button to
oppose the tabling motion so we can have
this debate on this very important
amendment
the chair recognizes representative ladd
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you
very much madam speaker
if i know the fifth us circuit court of
appeals in new orleans got it right in
putting a hold on the vaccine mandate in
the workplace
if i further know that public interest
is best served by maintaining the
liberty of individuals to make their own
intensely intensely personal decisions
however
if i also know this bill as amended has
created a constitutional conflict
between personal rights
and the rights of private business
owners
without what i then support this tabling
motion but know that a mandatory vaccine
work requirement is counterproductive to
our economy and way of life thank you
the question
is should hb 255 be laid upon the table
press the green button for yes and red
for no
the voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
yes
[Music]
representative craig
representative mackey
uh
have all members voted who were here
when the question was put
house will attend to the state of the
vote
213 voting yes
142 voting no
hb 255 is laid upon the table
oh here's your stuff
madam speaker
for what purpose does the member rise
i'd like to make a motion on hb 607
i
i don't have the bill in front of us yet
thank you
okay
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred hb 607
fn an act establishing a local education
savings account for students having
considered the same report the same
without the following amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment
the minority of the commitment committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative marja reporter for the
minority of the committee
the amendment two two five zero h
printed in house record 48 pages 101 to
106. are you ready for the question
i know representation oh if i apologize
what is your motion
thank you madam speaker i sorry i jumped
the gun
um
i would like to table
607 i'd like to ask for a division vote
and do a pi
okay thank you so the motion on the
floor is to table hb 607
a roll call has been requested by
representative cordell spelaine is that
sufficiently seconded yes it is
members will take their seats this will
be a roll call vote
but you guys
i don't want this bill to pass
the motion on the floor is to table
hb607
n
representative wolf is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
as i know if i know
that hb 607 as impactful as it would be
on local property taxes and school
student education has barely been vetted
at all house will be in order
and madam speaker if i know that the
consequences of moving forward on such a
program that commits local property tax
dollars would be enormous and long
lasting for many communities and madam
speaker since i also know that we just
passed a school choice program only four
months ago and it has already gone
well over budget
and if i know that there is no
accountability for the education results
from this bill
therefore
would i now press the green button and
table this legislation
thank you
representative ladd is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much madam speaker
if i know there are some who oppose
local education freedom accounts as
proposed in 607
because of misinformation disseminated
by the education establishment
claiming that program diverts taxpayer
money from the traditional public
schools but that is not reality because
this program will spend much much less
per pupil than average new hampshire
public school cost per student of twenty
thousand dollars per student
and if i know that hb 607 is enabling
legislation
requiring a 60 percent super majority of
district voters
that can also be rescinded by a similar
action at any time
and if i believe educational opportunity
provided by a local education freedom
account is created first and foremost to
give parents the power to choose the
educational options and core knowledge
learning that are best for their
children while public school education
as a result of education choice will
benefit and innovate
more competition in education would i
then press the red button to oppose the
tabling motion
the motion on the floor is to table
house bill 607 fn if you're in favor you
will press the green button if you are
opposed you will press the red button
voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
have all members
oh wait a minute
representative mcbride
thank you
have all members
voted
had the opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
yes 187 no 170
hb607 is laid upon the table
wow
the house will be in order
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred hb 608
fn a local and act relative to the
formula for determining funding for an
adequate education having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative rick glad
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative david
luno for the minority of the committee
for what purpose does the member rise uh
madam speaker i rise to make a motion
what is your motion i'd like to make a
motion to table
hb608
the motion on the floor is to table
hb608 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye division boat
okay i heard ya
division boat has been called members
will take their seats
division
okay yeah i thought so
okay
he called it before
yeah
this is a division boat members should
be taking their seats
the motion on the floor is to lay hb 608
on the table the chair recognizes
representative luna for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you very much madam chair if i
know
that here in new hampshire
our school funding
framework is broken it's broken for
students and it's broken for taxpayers
and if i know
that many
legislators have heard from their
constituents
about
doing something to fix school funding
and if i know that house bill 608 isn't
a perfect solution
and if i know that house bill 608 does
need some more work
would i oppose the tabling motion so
that another motion could be made for uh
for an interim study of 608 thank you
madam chair
representative ladd is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much madam speaker if i know i don't
want to be here on friday
and if i also know that there is a
working subcommittee comprised of folks
from finance division two
and policy working on the adequacy
formula at this time would i then
support the motion made and vote green
thank you
the motion on the floor is to table
hb608 if you're in favor you press the
green button if you are opposed you'll
press the red button the voting stations
will be open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative allegro
representative baldassaro
representative di lorenzo
representative phadolfy
representative edwards
representative gallagher
representative leflam
representative lasallus
you're good now representative
representative edwards you're all said
representative melvin
representative jody nelson
representative porter
representative shirtless
representative stapleton
representative rhodes
try it
representative pearl
representative weber
representative warden representative
welch
representative harvey bolia
represent warden you're all set
is harvey bullia here
have all members had the opportunity to
vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
193 yes 154 no hb 608 is laid upon the
table
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred sb 44 an
act establishing the new hampshire
workforce pathway program having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative glenn cordelli for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative marjah reporter for
the minority of the committee for what
purpose does the member rise to make a
motion madam speaker please state your
motion i'd like to make a motion to
table sb44 the motion
on the floor is to table h sp 44 are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
what
you did
i didn't hear
did someone say division
[Applause]
okay it's a division vote
i really need people to speak a little
louder because i honestly did not hear
anyone
so this will be a division boat
members will take their seats
division
[Music]
okay
i have to get it out of my mouth first
okay representative porter is recognized
to make a parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker if i know that sb 44
proposes a worthwhile program to help
our constituents in our state
and really deserves to be heard and if i
also know i prepared a nice speech and
i'd really like to give it would you
please vote no i'm laying on the table
so we can move on with this bill thank
you
representative ladd is recognized for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you very
much madam speaker
if i know by voting green we will get on
with business even sooner please vote
green
the motion on the floor is to table sb44
are you ready uh are you ready the
voting stations will be open for 30
seconds
representative baruti
representative bergeron
representative amanda bolden
representative deschez
representative phadolfy
representative infantine
representative mcbride representative
perez representative post representative
page
representative terry
representative vale
representative welch representative
walsh
representative hall
representative bowes
all set representative perez thank you
represent walsh
nope
have all members had the opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the boat
201 yays 148 nays
sb 44 is laid upon the table
on to election law
all right
the majority of the committee on
election law to which was referred hb 87
an act relative to the definition of
electioneering having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative joe sweeney for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
paul bergeron for the minority of the
committee
amendment 2246h
printed in house record 48 page 75. are
you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the most and the
amendment is adopted
right
the question now is on the majority
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended is somebody yelling at me again
who is
rising uh representative partial
for what purpose does the member rise i
would like to table this
uh amendment or table this vote okay
to table the bill
the motion on the floor is to table hb
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is
this will be a roll call vote members
will take their seats
i don't know
is anybody
opi
no pis
paul is
okay
no joke
that he was doing it
okay this will be a roll call vote
on tabling hb 87. if you are in favor
you will press the green button if you
are opposed you will press the red
button voting stations will be open for
30 seconds
oh i forgot the pis i'm so sorry
we're already voting i'm so sorry
sorry
representative in time
so
representative welkowitz
representative trottier
representative stevens representative
sullivan representative to berge
representative page
representative muirhead representative
mel moran
representative merchant
representative philadelphia
representative egan
have all members had the opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the boat
166 years 184 nays motion fails
the question is now on the majority
report of ought to pass this amended on
hb
87 representative bergeron
thank you madam speaker
house bill 87 would allow anyone other
than election officials to enter a
polling place where wearing clothing or
paraphernalia that promotes a candidate
party ballot question
and stay inside the polling place for as
long as they want to
the majority report argues that new
hampshire election electioneering laws
should be repealed
because a minnesota election hearing law
was struck down by the supreme court
well the supreme court did not say that
states could not prohibit campaign
displays inside polling places
they said that quote
minnesota has not supported its good
intentions with a law capable of
reasoned application
the court went on to credit the states
of texas and california for having
electioneering laws that prohibit the
members suspend
the house needs to come to order please
take your conversations outside i can
hardly hear him speaking
thank you thank you madam speaker
the court credited the states of texas
and california for having electioneering
laws that prohibited campaign clothing
and paraphernalia
they did so in what the court called
more lucid terms
and indicated that those laws could be
consistently interpreted and enforced
like the laws in california and texas
new hampshire's election hearing laws
are detailed clear and can be
consistently applied
so what could happen if this bill passes
other than election officials anyone
wearing campaign materials can gather
loiter congregate inside the polling
place stay there for as long as they
want there's no restrictions as to
whether or not these people can be
from the town from the ward from the
city from the voting district they can
come in from anywhere and stay as long
as they want
some polling sites are located in school
gymnasiums in nashua i know we have
several that are that way
and our election officials will pull out
bleachers so that observers can sit
comfortably
and be out of the flow of voters and
election officials
if this bill passes candidates and
campaign workers can pack into those
bleachers and conduct pep rallies for
their issues or their candidates for as
long as they want to
some of our other polling sites are
quite small and have very limited space
for voting equipment voters and election
workers let alone for candidates and
campaigners who want to work the voters
inside the polls
if this bill passes candidates and
campaign workers can be anywhere in the
public area
there are no restrictions in this bill
and how close they can get to the voters
outside the building voters have a 10
foot wide safe passage corridor leading
to the entrance but once they're inside
the building that safe passage corridor
disappears
undoubtedly candidates or campaign
workers from all major parties will try
to take advantage of this last minute
opportunity this is not party specific
and why wouldn't they why not have a
last-minute opportunity to influence
voters
so if you want to let's make a deal
crowd in the bleachers or a circus-like
atmosphere in the public areas of the
polling place then vote for the bill
but if you want to ensure safe and clear
paths for voters inside the polling
place and want to help our election
officials keep the polling places free
of obstructions for their work and for
voter traffic then please press the red
no button when it comes time to cast
your vote on this legislation so a
subsequent motion can be
provided thank you
the chair recognizes the member from
salem representative sweeney
thank you madam speaker i'm at d2
the goal of our new hampshire house
majority has been simple this term
we're making it easier to vote and
harder to cheat
whether you wear a red hat house will be
in order
whether you're wearing a red hat a blue
shirt or a yellow scarf you should be
allowed to vote on election day we made
significant changes to this bill from
when it was introduced during committee
to ensure that voters have the right to
vote in whatever appropriate clothing
item they're wearing
we've made sure to further refine our
existing law so that poll workers and
those that are working the polls on
behalf of the town or the state or the
challengers appointed by the party are
still prohibited from wearing political
paraphernalia this is to ensure that no
one can feel intimidation when they are
receiving their ballot or when they're
casting it
when someone who is registered to vote
gets to their polling location gets
their name crossed off the checklist and
is handed their ballot by the ballot
clerk that individual deserves to vote
period
i'm going to let you all in on a little
trade secret
no one going to vote is undecided when
they get to the polling location
we all love to hold our signs outside
with our volunteers trying to convince
people last minute to vote for them but
when people are coming to the polling
location they already know how they're
voting
this bill would not impact that at all
just as signs placed along the roadway
have no impact on how somebody votes
allowing someone to wear a hat or a
t-shirt into the polling location would
have no further impact on that right to
vote or how that individual voter will
vote
the supreme court as was mentioned
struck down in 2018 a minnesota law that
prohibited voters from wearing t-shirts
hats and buttons expressing political
views at polling places we should follow
that precedent and reform our laws
proactively before new hampshire ends up
before the supreme court please vote
green on hb 87 thank you very much
the question on the floor
is ought to pass as amended on hb 87 are
you ready for the question
division vote has been requested members
will take their seats
division
thank you
the question on the floor
is
the majority report of ought to pass as
amended on hb 87 representative bergeron
is recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you madam speaker
if i know that the minnesota election
hearing law struck down by the supreme
court was vague subject to conflicting
interpretations and generally
unenforceable
and if i know that new hampshire's
electioneering laws are similar to other
states laws that the supreme court
called lucid and they could be equitably
applied and enforced
and if i know that this bill does not
apply only to voters as they are in the
act of casting ballots
and if i know that allowing anyone and
any number of people for any length of
time to loiter gather congregate
campaign or disrupt the peace inside a
polling place
would be disrespectful toward our voters
and our election officials would i then
press the red no button so the
subsequent motion can be made
the chair recognizes representative
sweeney for our parliamentary inquiry
thank you madam speaker if i know that
our fundamental right to vote is sacred
and if i know we should be removing as
many unnecessary prohibitions on us
exercising the franchise to vote would i
now press the green button thank you
okay the question on the floor is
ought to pass is amended on hb 87 your
boating stations will be open for 30
seconds
okay
representative harvey boglia
representative rambo
representative weber
representative umberger representative
tripp representative spillsbury
representative testerman representative
to berge
representative thompson representative
told
representative sumero representative
marjorie smith representative timothy
smith representative suzanne smith
representative shirtless
representative
perez representative nordgren
representative osborne representative
oxel
representative partial representative
moran representative mann representative
lockman
representative leflam representative
langley representative judy
representative
hatch
representative philadelphi
representative alter
walt chiller excuse me
representative conley okay
have you had
thank you
oh
is
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
have all members voted who were
president when the question was put
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
186 years 164 nays the motion is adopted
and my truck
committee on election law to which was
referred house bill 327 act requiring
that voters show identification when
personally delivering absentee ballots
to town and city clerks having
considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study this day
quality for the committee
thank you mr speaker i'm at microphone
d1
we don't have you down for speaking sir
is this better we don't have we don't
there's no debate there's no debate
okay uh can you hear me now
there's no debate representative
my mistake
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
the committee report is adopted
majority committee on election water
which was referred house bill 514
an act relative to ballot column
rotation having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
instead of natalie wells from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is in
expedient to legislate representative
paul bergeron the minority of the
committee
the amendment is 2242-h
printed in house record 48 page 96 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor of the amendment
say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron to speak against the committee
report thank you mr speaker
house bill 514 pertains to the issue of
rotating the parties and names of
candidates on the ballot
this process
is a result of what's called the primacy
effect
which refers to the advantage that a
party or candidate receives based on
their ballot position
state law now requires the secretary of
state to rotate party columns and
candidate positions
the majority report states that the bill
will allow the secretary of state to
increase the range of deviation for
ballot rotations from one to two percent
that's not correct
the current law states that the average
deviation quote shall be as close to 0
as practicable
in testimony before the committee the
secretary of state's office said it
would be easier for them to design
ballots if the allowable deviation was
increased
easier and less complicated
this new hampshire supreme court
considered a case relative to primacy
effects back in 2006
and during testimony before the court
the secretary of state said quote the
primacy effect can confer as much as a
six to ten percent advantage upon
candidates
and in its final decision the court
found that the primacy effect does quote
confer an advantage in elections
and the court also affirmed new
hampshire's constitutionally guaranteed
equal right to be elected
ultimately the rights and interests of
voters and candidates deserve greater
consideration and support than the wish
of the secretary of state for an easier
less complicated process
probably everyone in this room has
either been involved in a recount or
known someone who has been involved in a
recount due to a very close election
the primacy effect does confer an
advantage in elections
current law says that the average
deviation shall be as close to zero
percent as practicable
let's ensure that voters have the final
say in who gets elected not ballot
position
please press the red no button when the
majority report comes up for a vote
the chair recognizes representative
wells to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker thank you mr
speaker
hb 514 addresses the method for
determining the column rotation on
ballots
the bill originally proposed an
open-ended change to the formula
the bill as now amended proposes that
the formula used can have a deviation up
to two percent rather than the current
one percent
the secretary of state's office is
responsible for preparation of ballots
while we are more familiar with the
process for the order of the candidate's
name there is also a process for the
order of the columns that are by party
every 10 years after the census and
redistricting
the rotation order for the party of the
column is recalculated this work is done
by the secretary of state's office
currently the law provides that the
order for rotations on the ballots will
be figured based on the smallest
representative districts the districts
you and i run in
and then there needs to be a balance of
those representative districts within
each of the 24 districts
but those people on the other side of
the wall so to speak
when that calculation is done the
average deviation across the state for
an equal rotation
for being in the first column must be no
greater than one percent
the latest rotation in effect resulted
in 1.17
average deviation from equal rotation
statewide
this formula went into effect after the
2010 census
in the previous decade there had been
court cases on the method used
the court ruled that the previous
methods used to prepare ballot rotations
were not enough to ensure that the right
to be elected a unique new hampshire
right was protected
so the state went from simply having the
first column assigned to the party that
won the previous election
to a random rotation
because our law rsa
6565 sets the highest priority on house
districts
then moves to the senate the initial
work is necessarily largely manual since
there is a striking lack of uniformity
in these districts
in a state election the secretary of
state produces over one thousand
different ballots for 310 polling places
absentee ballots and yukaba ballots
the present formula that the secretary
of state's office must follow
working from house districts requires
much of the initial work to be done
manually
by increasing the upper limit from one
to two percent it is believed it will
not statistically impact any primary
effect and be able to cover the governor
the executive council federal offices
state and senate etcetera
no other state has this complexity
this legislation is being introduced to
continue continue the randomized ballot
rotation in a manner that protects the
right to be elected while providing a
less burdensome way to do it
not just to make the secretary of
state's office job easier
the majority of the election law
committee agreed with the request being
reasonable and i ask for your support of
the recommendation of ought to pass with
the amendment thank you mr speaker
the question before us is
on house bill 514 the majority report of
octopass has amended mr speaker
i'm at a3
over here yes
um i have a point of order is
videotaping aloud in the chamber
no it is not all right thank you
okay that that was we will clarify that
that was a request by one member from
another member but no it is not allowed
so
all members take that to uh to heart and
it is not allowed
so i'm excuse me mr speaker follow up if
i may yes what is following um so if a
member is allowed to videotape upon
request the member is not allowed
even with a request that is correct that
is correct okay thank you they were
unaware of it oh okay thank you
okay the
question is on house bill 514 the
majority report of arthur pass has
amended
are you ready for the question
who's requested the roll call
representative barbara representative
barbara griffin has requested roll calls
that's officially seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call
vote members take your seats this will
be a roll call vote
so
i also come to water
the chair recognizes representative
bergeron for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the supreme court has
determined that the primacy effect
influences even to a small degree the
outcome of new hampshire elections
and if i know that the new hampshire
supreme court has cited new hampshire's
constitutionally guaranteed equal right
to be elected
and if i know under the current law that
there is no current upper limit for the
range of deviation pertaining to ballot
rotation it only requires that the
secretary of state get as close to zero
percent as possible
and if i know that the rights and
interests of voters and candidates
deserve greater consideration than the
state department's wishes for an easier
and less complicated process to
implement an existing law would i then
press the red no button so that a
subsequent motion can be made
the chair recognizes representative
wells for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know the
statutory formula for party column
rotation is complex and subjective and
cannot be easily explained
if i know that our new england sister
states and other states with election
day registration like minnesota and
wyoming have a far simpler rotation that
can be easily explained
and i know that the formula to do this
used by new hampshire is one of the most
complicated in the country
requesting balancing among
representatives and within senate
districts
and if i know that this bill as amended
does not change the formula rotation but
allows a slightly higher deviation which
will not have an adverse effect on our
constitutional rights to be elected
would i now press the green button and
support the committee recommendation of
o2 otpa thank you mr speaker
the question is on house bill 514
majority report about to pass as amended
this is going to be a roll call vote if
you're in favor you will press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
representative alessia
representative cannon
representative gamarlo
representative judy
representative nunes
representative rich
representative warden
walmart vice president had the
opportunity to vote
household attend to the state of the
vote
under an 88 voting 865 voting no and the
committee reports adopted
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred 531 fn local
act relative to determining the
qualifications of voters establishing
provisional voter registration and
provisional ballots consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative wayne mcdonald for
the majority of the committee
speaker
can i finish reading oh i'm sorry i
thought that was done no my apologies mr
speaker the minority of the committee
have been considered the same being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate senator
heidi hammer for the minority of the
committee uh what reason does a member
rise thank you mr speaker barbara
griffin c3 i move to table hb531
that is a legitimate motion the motion
is to table house bill 531
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those oppose nay
house bill 531 is laid on the table
the eyes happen
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill 535
an act relative
to qualified voter affidavit having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendations of the bill be
referred
for interim study senator wayne mcdonald
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate president of
connie lane from the minority of the
committee
mr speaker
for what reason does a memorize
c3 barbara griffin i rise to table hb
535. that is a legitimate motion
the motion is to table house bill 535.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and house bill 535 is
laid on the table
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill 554
an act relative to temporary absence
from domicile for voting purposes been
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
senator barbara griffin for the majority
of the committee
a minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report as a
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator russell
muir head for the minority of the
committee chair recognizes
senator griffin brewer
thank you mr speaker i moved to table hb
5 5 4. that is a proper motion the
motion before us is the table
hb554 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and house bill 544 is
laid on the table
majority of the committee on departments
of administration
executive department and administration
were to which was referred house bill 84
enact declaring
as
owner only judge day and renaming the
new terminal at portsmouth international
airport at peace in her honor having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senate of john
scitech for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpediential legislation mark allegro
for the minority of the committee
the amendment is
2097 h printed in house record 48 page
75. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question before us now is the
majority report what to pass as amended
on house bill 84. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in house bill 84 the
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on executive
departments and administration to which
was referred house bill 204 enact
proclaiming january 24th as granny d day
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator mark allegro from the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative timothy fortnell for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes
representative mcguire
thank you mr speaker i moved to place
house bill 204 on the table
the motion the motion that is a
legitimate emotion the motion before us
is to lay house bill 204 on the table
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
we had we uh we had requests for a
division
so
we this will be a division vote
division
yep
schultz
this will be a division vote the chair
recognizes representatives for a
parliamentary inquiry
the house will come to water
member has a right to be heard
i'm sorry mr speaker i didn't hear you
say yes i apologize yes go ahead thank
you mr speaker
if i know that there is a philosophical
difference
that
many of us espouse to encourage our
citizens to
pull for
days to honor granite staters
if i know
that
[Music]
granny d in particular
is a national and granite state icon
and if i know my speech would have only
been 90 seconds
then i would push
the red button
to just let that
go for a real vote thank you
joe recognizes representative mcguire
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that the governor has declared
granny d day
multiple times without us having to tell
himself
would i not vote with the overwhelming
majority of the committee
and lay this on the table thank you
the question before us is too late house
bill 204 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative callie pitts
representative bunker
representative ham representative
gamarlo
representative judy
representative macbeth
representative marsh
representative perez
representative rich
representative sweeney
representative warden
representative baxter
of all members had an opportunity to
vote
that were present
household 10 to the state of the vote
229 voting yay 118 voting nay house bill
204 is laid on the table
[Music]
majority committee on executive
departments and administration to which
was referred house bill 275
an act relative to the governor's power
to initiate a state of emergency and
various emergency powers having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator tony leakas from the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator jc
grotty for the minority of the committee
the amendment
is 2235
h printed in record 48 page 90.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is
majority report about the past as
amended the chair recognizes
representative
grota
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i'm here at a2
current law
rsa
4 colon 45c
allows this body
to meet
and
address and terminate executive orders
based on concurrent resolutions this can
be this is done by the house and the
senate
and we all know
that
we honor our commitment to
our constituents
and we will come when we are called
to meet
the fact that this lot has not happened
yet and did not happen last year when
the governor ex
executed his orders physics
does not mean that we need yet another
law
to tell us what our responsibilities are
when they already exist in statute thank
you i i encourage people to vote against
the otp
a
motion
could the members suspend for a minute
please
yeah
all right
hopefully we can keep it this quiet
remember may continue
i was done i just
i
i hope that people heard me i encouraged
the um body to vote against the otpa
because rsa 45
already addresses our ability to
terminate
executive orders by concurrent
resolutions thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes
representative leakes to speak for the
committee report thank you mr chair
when an emergency strikes the governor
needs the power to deal with the
situation promptly
this bill permits the governor to
declare a state of emergency for up to
21 days he can then renew that state of
emergency up to three times for up to 21
days each
this permits the governor to maintain
his emergency powers for up to 84 days
without requiring the legislature to
meet emergencies have more than one
phase there is the initial phase which
requires quick and decisive action which
the governor is better suited to than
the legislature
however after the immediate problems
have been dealt with the emergency
transitions to a management phase where
there may be still serious problems that
may last for a long time
but the situation does not require the
same level of urgent response as the
initial phase
after the initial phase the people of
new hampshire need to be involved in the
process through their legislators
if the legislature believes that the
state of emergency should last beyond 84
days it may vote to renew it for up to
90 days at a time and can renew it as
often as needed
even during i mean concern has been
raised that there may be a need to
extend the state of emergency but it
might not be possible for the
legislature to meet even during the
recent emergency the legislature was
able to meet in less than that amount of
time
we have shown that we have the
creativity and flexibility to meet and
do our duty even under difficult
circumstances
while the current statute permits the
legislature to meet and vote to end a
state of emergency there is a
significant difference between the
legislature having the power to meet to
end a state of emergency and it being
required to meet to extend one
meeting and voting to extend the state
of emergency makes it clear to our
constituents that we are doing our job
rather than
sitting on our hands and leaving the
responsibility to the governor
part 1 article 37 of our constitution
states in part
in the government of this state the
three essential powers thereof to it the
legislative executive and judicial ought
to be kept as separate from and
independent of each other as the nature
of a free government will admit
a state of emergency is a truly
extraordinary thing
it is the suspension of this
constitutionally mandated separation of
powers well that may be necessary to
respond quickly to an emergency
after some point in time it is no longer
justified and the legislature must
resume its constitutionally mandated
task of guiding the way any remaining
problems created by the emergency are
managed that must be an active role not
just standing aside and acquiescing to
whatever the governor chooses to do
also if the state of emergency does need
to extend beyond 84 days the legislature
should have the governor's back an
actively declared support of how the
emergency is being handled if there is
opposition to the state of emergency we
should share in the blame or credit of
extending it that is our responsibility
as representatives of our constituents
legislature affects the future this bill
is not a referendum on how the recent
state of emergency was handled
even if we believe that the current
governor handled the recent emergency
perfectly we need to consider the
possibility that a future governor may
respond in a less appropriate manner
please join me in pressing the green
button to support the committee
recommendation
thank you mr speaker a division has been
requested members will mr speaker
a roll call has been requested is that
officially seconded is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
roll call
thank you
tomorrow
do you know where she
so
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
grote for a parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker mr speaker if i know that
this body will come
to
a session at your calling and we have
done this
as an example of today in extraordinary
times
and if i know that this body can
terminate the governor's executive
orders at any time
and if i know
that
we are aware of our constitutional
and constituent duties
i would press
read
on otpea thank you so that another
motion can be made
chair recognizes representative mcguire
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this spill
as amended
carefully and constitutionally separates
the short-term emergencies that the
governor
is
responsible for and capable for
and the long-term emergencies that
require the legislature to take action
and if i know that this is the final
installation
of the emergency
bills that we passed last year by
overwhelming majorities would i not
press the green button thank you
question before us
is the majority report
as amended on hb 275 this is a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
uh
representative smith
alright
um
representative eamon kelly
that should be it
fall members president had an
opportunity to vote
household 10 to the state of the vote
190 voting yay 165 vote in a committee
reports adopted
majority majority of the committee on
executive departments administration
which was referred house bill 414
act relative to evacuations under a
state of emergency having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator diane schuett for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
tony leakes for the minority of the
committee
this is going to be a division vote with
just parliamentary inquiries so this
will be a division vote members take
your seats
division
[Music]
who requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote rule
[Music]
house will come to order
this will be a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative lucas for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know there is a
long-standing american tradition of
considering a person's home their castle
and that this is reflected in the
constitution law and tradition
and if i believe that following that
tradition the final decision on leaving
one's home must be up to the homeowner
even in a state of emergency
and further if i know that this bill
relieves first responders of any
obligation to assist someone who refuses
to evacuate under a state of emergency
lastly if i know that current practice
is to inform people that they should
evacuate but not compel them to do so
would i press red to oppose the
committee amendment of the committee
motion so another motion may be made
thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes the representative
goalie for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker over here a1
mr speaker if i know the purpose of
emergency evacuation orders is to
provide for safety of the public and
first responders
and mr speaker if i know this bill would
remove the requirement of individuals to
evacuate during an emergency
and mr speaker if i know this would
create both a safety and liability issue
for our first responders as there is
nothing that prevents someone who has
chosen not to evacuate to later call for
help as the emergency situation
escalates
and mr speaker if i know there is no way
to keep record of those who have chosen
to disregard the emergency evacuation
order
would i join with the bipartisan
majority of the edna committee and push
the green button
this is the question is on house bill
414 the majority report have been
expedient to legislate
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose
you will press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative gallagher
representative emon kelly
representative woodcock
representative langley
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
198 voting yay 156 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 91 fn
an act relative to death benefits of
first responders who die from suicide
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass
senator peter leishman for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
representative irf declared a conflict
and did not participate
the committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 254 enact relative
to the placement of minors in secure
settings having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator keith earth for them
for the committee
the amendment is 21628
printed in house record 48 pages 88 89.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those oppose nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative rice
to speak in favor of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
i rise today in support of hb 254
this bill addresses best practice for
children in the juvenile justice system
this policy was unanimously supported by
the house
and finance made two changes to the bill
before finance also unanimously
supported hb 254.
the policy changes are supported by the
children and family law
the two changes in the amendment are
straightforward the first change updates
the effective dates of the bill
the second change updates the judicial
discretion portion of the bill
hb 254 was retained in finance as a
result the date changes were needed to
give dcyf sufficient time
to prepare for changes made by hb 254
the judicial discretion portion of the
bill gives judges discretion to commit a
child to sysc when the judge believes
circumstances require this type of
intervention
currently
a child must commit three separate
crimes if they do not meet conditions
for commitment
we believe the amended judicial
discretion is more robust and provides
for the best interest of the child and
the public safety
the underlying bill is unchanged from
the policy endorsed by the children and
family law committee and unanimously
supported by this house
it is important to remember that
children in the juvenile justice system
are released from sysc and the system at
18 years of age the goal of the juvenile
justice system is to prepare the child
to be a productive adult member of the
new hampshire community
in 2017
the last time this legislature changed
sysc commitment standards the sysc
census was nearly 70 children on average
two-thirds of these kids were
recommitted to sysc after release
that is just over six
of every 10 children committed
are released and then recommitted of the
nearly 70 children in 2017
46 of these children were weak
recommitted
in 2017 the changes eliminated most
misdemeanors from commitment
many people objected to the changes
some people were afraid of these
children and others were concerned there
was a lack of available treatment
i was one of those people objecting
i didn't believe that i did not believe
that new hampshire was prepared for the
change and wanted a smaller change
but i was wrong
after passage of the bill the census
dropped quickly the census dropped from
nearly 70 children in 2017
to about 12 children today
as importantly there has been no
widespread lack of service for these
children
in fact our service delivery system has
expanded significantly
in part to deal with the children no
longer at sysc
as my friend from
another friend will outline
of the 12 children at sysc today half or
more are incarcerated at sysc for
misdemeanor offenses based on dcyf data
adults generally are not incarcerated
for misdemeanor offenses so why are we
locking up our children
in fact there are more beneficial
services available for children rather
than incarceration
however this bill will continue to
incarcerate children who commit serious
violent offenses
it also give judges to stress discretion
as mentioned previously to incarcerate
the child for other offenses when that
is the only option to assure safety
the remaining children will be treated
in the existing children's system of
care
dcyf indicates that 75 percent of all
children incarcerated at syfc have a
behavioral health issue
the system of care is created to address
children's behavioral health needs
the system of care is the least
expensive and most effective way to
treat our children
our juvenile justice system has two
goals
one to protect the public
and two to prepare children to be
productive adults
hb 254 accomplishes these goals by
incarcerating serious violent offenders
and providing
residential treatment for other children
please please reaffirm the unanimous
house vote the unanimous finance
committee vote and the 18-1 vote of the
children and family law committee hb 254
is the best way to treat our children
and deserves our support
thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative lynn
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
first uh
ladies and gentlemen i have to offer my
apology
as was just noted
it was recognized that there was a 21-0
vote of the finance committee in favor
of this legislation
i was one of those 21 folks
when this first came before finance i
saw the problem that i'm well i will
talk to you about in a moment and i had
to frankly swallow hard to to vote for
it but i did
however the recent rash of property
crimes around the country including
shoplifting and smashing grabs
including some that have happened very
recently as within two weeks before
christmas
in this state
have led me to change my mind and to
believe that this bill
would represent bad public policy and
should not be enacted
under present law
a juvenile cannot be committed to a
juvenile detention facility for any
theft crime
false statement or false swearing crime
or breach of the peace types type crime
if such crimes would be a misdemeanor if
committed by an adult
but there is a so-called three strikes
exception and it's important to
understand that what that exception does
is to allow
but not require a minor to be committed
for the types of offenses
that i just spoke about
if he or she has been found delinquent
of three past offenses
hb 254 significantly expands
the crimes for which a minor can never
be committed to include essentially all
non-violent crimes
even if they are felonies
of particular concern in what in light
of what's been happening around the
country
this bill prohibits commitment of minors
for property offenses
no matter how much property is stolen or
damaged unless the miner is either armed
with a weapon or there is a threat of or
actual infliction of bodily injury
for example
under the bill if you and your spouse go
away for the weekend
and return to find that while you're
going while you were gone your house was
broken into by a minor and you are
literally cleaned out of thousands of
dollars worth of property
the miner doesn't have to worry
about spending even one day
in juvenile detention
although i
am clear that the message that this bill
sends the message
that property rights are not important
and that if all you do is steal
someone's property it's no big deal
although i'm sure this was not intended
by by the committees that that
considered this
this is exactly the kind of message
that the woke district attorneys have
been sending around the country in
places like los angeles
san francisco and philadelphia
and we have seen the consequences of
their policies
please do or not allow this folly in new
hampshire
amendment 2162h
as we've just passed
makes this bill even worse
because it eliminates the three the
three strikes provision
so that under this amendment in the
example that i just gave the juvenile
would not have to worry about spending
even one day in juvenile commitment
even if he had done and been convicted
of doing the exact same thing
three times previously it's important to
note that although the amendment
contained adds a new section m
to the statute
which allows the commitment of a minor
for any felony offense
but but it applies only if the miner
only if the court finds that the minor
poses a substantial risk to the public
of causing serious bodily injuries so
once again
this this amendment even with subsection
m does not change the message
that if you are only a property offender
um it's no big deal and you don't have
to worry about
spending even one day in commitment
i i have to emphasize here
i am the last person who takes the view
that you know the way we should deal
with juveniles is lock them up and throw
away the key
i absolutely believe
that incarceration commitment of a of a
minor should be the last possible thing
that happens and is is a very rare
situation that it should happen in a
property offense only
but that is that system of making it the
last
the last possible choice already exists
under under present law
the judge has can can only employ impose
commitment as a last resort
have to make fines of fact
find by clear and convincing evidence
that there's nothing left that would be
appropriate
but this bill by saying never
never can a judge find out if it's a
property crime only just goes too far
one final point i would make and then
i'll shut up
removing the possibility of commitment
reduces incentives for minors to become
invested in other dispositions that with
other less severe dispositions which may
very well be appropriate in most cases
this is simply a reflection of the
carrot and the stick phenomenon
there are some miners who are resistant
to who do or who do not believe that
they need treatment or rehabilitation
programs
and unless they understand that if they
don't comply
with a less onerous form of disposition
such as treatment counseling therapy
whatever
unless they unless they understand that
if they don't comply with that the judge
can use the stick of commitment
the incentive to successfully complete
treatment programs just won't be there
for some for some juveniles in short
ladies and gentlemen i believe that this
proposal is a solution in search of a
problem
current law in this area is fine and i
urge you to press the get the red button
to vote no so that another motion may be
made thank you mr speaker does the
member yield to questions
i do mr speaker representative edwards
i'm here for motion
he still has the floor right now
representative
he's yielded the questions we'll get to
your motion
representative edwards uh
i i think representative rice and
representative lynn are the ones up for
questions at this point is that is that
not correct because i'm here
representative lynn is up for questions
right now yes sir
i i'm not the one with the question
representative
thank you for taking the question
um
is it my understanding from from what
you just said that in fact
uh the judges have less
flexibility
for what they see fit under this law and
they're prescribed to not commit
someone unless it is an offense that is
listed
that's exactly correct this bill
reduces judicial discretion and there's
just no reason to do it there's no
reason to believe that judges are you
know willy-nilly
uh committing uh minors to to the to uh
juvenile commitment for property
offenses i i would be frank i don't know
this but i would be frankly
extremely surprised if there was anyone
in ydc
right now
and a committed sentence for only a
non-property crime and that's as it
should be because it rarely if ever
happened but this would say it can never
happen and as i said that just goes too
far
remember yield to further questions
i do representative cody
you may inquire
representative i wave my question
you wave your question okay
senator bel desairo yeah mr speaker i
was ready to vote for this but now i'd
like to make a motion to table
that is a proper motion
the motion before us is the table house
bill 254
division has been requested roll call mr
speaker roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
yes it is sufficiently seconded
rocole
mr speaker
yes representative
i would also like to speak for the pie
he's
this is a division vote
the motion before us is the table house
bill 254.
the chair
roll call by mistake this is a roll call
vote
the chair recognizes representative
belanger for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill helps young
students in care and that
this reduces the number of students that
are committed to sysc which is a goal in
this house in the children and family
committee
and across the country would i then
press the red button and not support the
motion to table this bill
representative
the chair recognized representative
griffin for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that this bill is not limited to
students this is an issue of majority a
minority
and if i know that this bill reduces
judicial discretion in connection with
care
and treatment of minors
and if i also know
that incarceration
which this is not this is
confinement
under juvenile laws
can often be a great incentive
and finally if i know that there was no
production that there was a problem in
new hampshire currently with this would
i now press
the
green button to lay this matter on the
table thank you
the question before us is to lay on the
table house bill 254 this is a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative gotling
represent perez
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
151 voting 204 voting nay
the motion to table fails
the chair recognizes representative mr
speaker over here d1
yes why does a member rise for a motion
state your motion
i'd like to uh having having voted on
the prevailing side i'd have i'd have
the
body reconsider house bill 275
we can't do that we're in the middle of
the debate we're we're in the middle of
a debate right now i'm sorry
i apologize yeah we're in the middle of
the debate
the chair recognizes representative
walmer
thank you mr speaker
i'm here at
a1
i rise today in support of house bill
254 as amended
the policy of this bill was fully vetted
by the children and family law committee
and passed unanimously by this house
the bill was then referred to finance
hb 254 does not have an appropriation
or a fiscal note
however the bill does have potential
indirect
financial impact
the bill could potentially reduce
the number of children incarcerated at
this
youth services center
which presently costs close to 14
million dollars a year
to operate
with an average daily census of 12 to 14
youth
this expensive
often inappropriate incarceration
is being replaced with high quality
appropriate treatment in community
settings
in 2017
this legislature decided
that non-institutional treatment was
better
produced better outcomes for children
than incarceration
to this end we haven't appropriated
millions of dollars
to create the system of care
the system of care has been building a
broad array of services for children
with behavioral problems
according to the new hampshire division
of children
family children and families
more than 75 percent of the children
incarcerated at sununu youth services
center experienced behavioral health
conditions
some of the children committed there for
serious violent offenses
and
for the public this is the best served
by incarceration of these children
however the other children are best
served by treatment in the system of
care
these services will provide optimal
treatment for children with behavioral
health needs
passing house bill 254 as amended makes
good financial sense and makes sense to
help children become effective adults
please join me and the unanimous report
of the finance committee in supporting
house bill 254 as amended
the question before us on house bill 254
is octopass as amended
are you ready for the question
division a roll call has been requested
who requested the roll call
senator sober requests the roll calls
that's officially seconded
yes it is officially seconded this will
be a roll call vote mr mr speaker i
think i was put down for a pi
we're not there yet but i got you
rocole
so
take something
house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative lin
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker but i've said what
i needed to say i'll wave off thank you
wave off geo recognizes representative
edwards for parliamentary inquiry uh
thank you mr speaker
if i knew
that
the finance committee
uh when we heard this bill were
completely convinced that we were making
the right decision
and if you are appropriately impressed
with the
words of the chairman of the children
and family law committee as well as
the senior member on
finance
and if you're also nevertheless
concerned about what you've heard from
the honorable representative from
windham
then would you go ahead and press the
green button
knowing that these issues have now been
surfaced and can be resolved in the
senate
so i
would recommend to you that you consider
getting this bill out of the house with
a green vote
this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative allegro
representative aldshiller
representative d silvestro
representative eaton
representative marsh
representative laurie sanborn
representative gayle samborn
representative stavis
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
voting yay 87 voting nay the committee
report is adopted mr speaker
why does it represent rise i'm going to
retry my emotion okay
i'd like to make a reconsideration
motion for house bill 275
and i ask my colleagues to vote red no
on that reconsideration
the motion is to reconsider house bill
are you ready for the question
division has been requested members take
your seats the vision has been requested
all right the question before us
is reconsideration in house bill 275
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative harb
representative diane kelly
representative perez
representative ayer
we're also
mr of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
170 voting a 184 voting a to reconsider
emotion fails
chair recognizes representative
dutsy for an announcement
i just wanted to announce that the first
meeting of the secular values
legislative caucus will meet over in the
lunch area
on my right near the windows
i invite all colleagues with a strong
belief that separation of church and
state is one of the strongest pillars in
our democracy to attend thank you
it's one it's 12 30.
you all have your lunches
everybody be back here by 1 15.
house is in recess
so
members take your seats please members
take your seat so we can get going
members take your seats please
you know
foreign
members take your seats please
so
let me
he's moving
oh
[Music]
all right
you're good
the house will come to order
the committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 398
an act making an appropriation to the
department of environmental services for
funding eligible wastewater projects
have been considered the same report the
same with the following amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator gerald
griffin for the committee
amendment 21178 printed in house record
48 page 92. you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
aye
those opposed nay
the amendment is adopted
we're now on
the committee report of otto pass as
amended
on house bill 398 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 412 nack make an
appropriation to the department of
environmental services for the purpose
of funding public water system projects
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill author
passed with amendment senator tracy
emrick for the committee
the amendment is 2172h
printed in house record 48 page 94. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted we're now on the committee
report as amended on 4-1-2 are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
bill's
against a nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 536 fn enact
relative to death benefits for public
works employees killed in the line of
duty in relative to workers compensation
offsets for certain retirement system
benefits having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
senator peter leichmann for the
committee
amendment is 211h
printed in house record 48 page 97 you
ready for the question on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those against nay
you guys have it the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the bill as
amended
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the committee report is adopted
the committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 591 fn
an act relative
to
certain liquor license fees having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass senator tracy emrick for the
committee
we do not have a debate
but we do have a question for um
representative romney that has agreed to
answer the question
uh zenobilicus
yes
representative abrami
um there are numerous of us who really
don't know where this bill came from why
it is
and we can't figure out how to vote so
if you could just give us a real brief
overview of what this is about that'll
help us thank you very much
thank you my friend from hudson
appreciate it
so this bill actually goes back to the
2019-2020 session
when vaping was all the rage we had to
come up with how do we tax nicotine
based
vaping products and then how do we
how do we license
vape shops
we just we took care of the the taxing
that in 2019 but when we got to the
to the licensing of vape shops in
committee we said well why don't we why
don't we make the license the same as
store retail stores that just sell
cigarettes
well we had a work session and the
liquor commission came back
and they said guess what we have a big
error in our statutes
that right now
places that only sell cigarettes
a good example would be a dollar store
dollar stores only sell cigarettes but
they don't sell beer and wine
they're only paying six dollars and you
say well how did that happen
well years ago in this body we decided
that for
retail stores that sell uh beer and uh
beer and liquor a beer in the wine
that they'll be an additional six
dollars only if they also sell
cigarettes on the license fee
so
so what happened that got interpreted to
for all stores that just sell cigarettes
only were being charged six dollars
which is an error and the liquor
commission told us it's a big error
so fine
we said
maybe we should retain this bill so that
we can have a hearing because it
involved 174 stores
that were only paying six dollars for a
cigarette
the ability to sell cigarette or tobacco
products
we had the hearing we wanted to make
sure we had a hearing so those 174
stores could have a say on this
we did have the hearing that fall and
there was really no complaints about it
by the way the vape shop folks
earlier on had no problem with the feed
that we had come up with
174 dollars
for one register goes up slightly if
there's more than one register in the
store that's the way the statutes work
so
ways and means uh we passed it that fall
down now we're into 20 because here we
are at the same time we were last a
couple of terms ago to the terminal
we were we were voting on retained bills
we voted
and the house
pretty much overwhelmingly voted yes on
the bill
and guess what happened in march
something called covet
and that bill got hung up in with all
the hundreds of bills that the senate
never took up
so it just died because the senate never
took the bill up
and i was volunteered by because it was
pretty unanimous out of that
2019 2020 ways and means committee we're
pretty anonymous that we should fix this
problem
so we we fixed it that those retail
stores pay
216 not to six dollars
and we had the hearing where the stores
were agreeing
so
so the bill went to edna this last
winter
because actually edna is the committee
that deals with
licensing
ways and means deals with
how much the fee should be
so e-dna passed it
on this floor we all voted for this bill
then
because in that bill that i filed
so i was volunteered to file the bill
the liquor commission asked for two ftes
we put it in the bill
edna took the two ftes out
so it really didn't have to go to
finance
but it
it went to finance anyway
but guess what so finance retained the
bill because they they had other bills
to worry about with the budget and
everything so they took it up this fall
they had a hearing
they passed it overwhelmingly so that's
the story
this bill passed three committees
ways of means
finance
edna
it passed this floor twice once last
session once this session
and here we are please vote yes on the
bill i hope that answers your question
mr speaker
uh up here at yes
yes representative i just could i ask
one question remember yield to a
question
yes yes thank you
yes isn't it true
that we have to obey
quite a lot of regulatory
rules
about
cigarette selling for the federal
government and especially the
national tobacco settlement
and that costs money
it costs a lot more than six dollars for
each visit
to
these stores that are paying six dollars
a year
and that that is why we needed to change
that
yep thank you thank you for the question
uh yes that's all true
i want to point out one thing first off
first you got to understand is that
when it comes to enforcement of our
liquor laws
there's an enforcement division of the
local commission
but to make things efficient
the liquor commission also oversees the
oversight of cigarettes
so the same enforcement officers
look at both so when they go to a store
that's why the six dollars
only if they already have a a license to
sell beer and wine it doesn't take that
much more as they go into a store
and that also has cigarettes
but to go to a store to oh to look
to to check his stuff he can't get very
far with six dollars
the other thing is you got to understand
that the uh
we have a tradition in this state
that we try to we use fees
to pay for things
we pay fees in this case for enforcement
of our local laws and our tobacco laws
so
i think we can all agree that at six
dollars to uh for 174 stores to go
and check if they're obeying our laws is
a bit bit low so the 216 again
three committed three committees
two house votes
and nobody complaining from the retail
stores that are impacted or the vape
shops so i think this is uh to me to me
was a housekeeping bill
but thank you all
has been called
members will take their seats
division
[Music]
the question before us is the ought to
pass amen ought to pass on house bill
591 fn a division has been called for
the chair recognizes
representative emrick for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the state operates on
fees fines and taxes
and some of the fees we have are to
inspect and
oversee
tax collection by retail stores it is
i believe is appropriate that we
charge
accordingly
please vote green
the question before us is the ought to
pass motion in house bill 591 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
were open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative ammon
representative altschiller
representative espitia
representative lundgren representative
mcbride
representative post
you're all set
the ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote 282 voting yay 66 voting a
committee report is adopted
oh i'm sorry
she's not here
okay
majority of the committee on fishing
game and marine resources which was
referred house bill 118 and act relative
to fish and game commission having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate president of
john close from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
the following amendment in the agreement
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment president
of ellen reed for the minority of the
committee
the question is on the motion
of itl mr speaker
can you hear me
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us
is itl on house bill 118 a roll call has
been requested
the chair recognizes representative lang
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill as written and
presented to the committee
has huge mechanical problems and
implementation problems and further mr
speaker if i know that this vote was a
bipartisan vote 75 percent of the
committee members agreeing that this was
a horrible bill that needs to be killed
would i now push the green button and
kill this fat bill
the question is on
the itl motion the majority itl motion
on house bill 118.
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative bill boyd representative
yokela
representative vose
representative sullivan
representative marjorie smith
representative mullen
representative tony lekkis
representative highland
representative barbara griffin
if all marmot's president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to say to the vote
three hundred and twenty
three hundred twenty one voting a thirty
one voting a committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on fish and
game and marine resources to which was
referred house bill 490 neck permitting
the use of live
auction action
game cameras having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill at the password amendment present
of timothy lang for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator
katherine harvey for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is
2140h on record in record 48 pages 95
through 96. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have an amendment is adopted
we have a request for a division and two
parliamentary inquiries so this will be
a division vote members take your seats
division
okay
wow
vision
the question before us is
the ought to pass that amended
on house bill 490 this is a division
vote
the chair recognizes representative
shirtless for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i come
to the well not as someone if i know
that i am coming to the well not as
someone who's opposed to hunting
but someone who's been a licensed hunter
in new hampshire since 1963
yes i'm really that old
and mr speaker
if i know that the committee was told by
colonel jordan of the new hampshire
fishing game
that if this bill is passed it would be
very difficult
to enforce
and mr speaker if i know there's a
strong tradition among new hampshire
sportsmen
in the belief of fair game fair chase
hunting
especially when it comes to deer
and the passage of this bill
is contrary to everything i was taught
as a kid about hunting in new hampshire
would i now push the red button and vote
no thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative lang for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know what this
bill does
is it clears up a private land rights
issue for private landowners that where
hunters put cameras on their land and it
requires them to put
the hunter to put his name on the camera
so it can be investigated by fish and
game if necessary and mr speaker if i
know further that
colonel jordan of the fish and game
department actually said that this bill
would clarify and clean up the law to
make it so it's actually more easily
enforceable
and lastly mr speaker if i just know
this is just good policy and we should
do it would i vote green and press the
green button
the question before us is the ought to
pass as amended
majority report on house bill 490.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative
representative blasic
representative kretien
represent mckay
baltimore mr president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to the state of the vote
under 95 voting yeah 159 voting may
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 103 fn
enacted an act establishing a dental
benefit under the state medicaid program
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
with amendment
president of josh apparel for the
majority majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and we're not able
to agree with the majority report with
the following resolution resolved as
inexpedient to legislate said jim
crowfall for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is
2214h record 48 pages
76-78
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the amendment is adopted mr speaker
representative sylvia at d2
state chair
why does the member rise i
would like to
move to table this bill and ask for a
division vote
all right it is a proper motion so the
motion
the motion is the table and the division
has been called
this will be a division
who
who requested a roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
vision
oh
this will be a division vote on the
tabling of house bill 103
the chair recognizes representative
sylvia for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know this bill is unnecessary
because medicaid participants already
have access to dental care if they
choose
and also be in order
and mr speaker if i know this bill
creates expanded entitlements
with no sunset provision
and will expand costs over time
and finally mr speaker
if i know the purported benefit of
future cost savings
is virtually impossible to measure
leaving taxpayers to pay for a program
whose benefits cannot be determined
would i then point of order mr speaker
e3
e1 rather state your point of order mr
speaker it was a tabling motion the
gentleman doing a pi is relating to the
substance of the bill in making a speech
with with respect representative we have
been allowing for some latitude
that's a lot of latitude mr speaker
the representative will continue
thank you mr speaker
and as i was saying
if i know of all of these things
and i want to table this bill would i
then press the green button
[Applause]
the chair recognizes representative
peterson for a parliamentary pearson for
a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker if i know
that a nearly unanimous vote in the
committee did not see it the way it has
been characterized
would i say let us not table this but go
on and discuss it and vote on it thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 103 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you
will press the green button if you are
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
back
[Music]
representative egan
uh representative brenzulo
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend this state of the vote
138 voting yay 213 voting may the
tabling motion fails
question is now on
the majority report about to pass as
amended
[Music]
the chair recognizes representative cole
fault to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
i'm at microphone d2
this bill is in fact unnecessary the
title of the bill is establishing a
dental benefit under the state medicaid
program
and contrary to to protestations
to the contrary
in fact dental benefits are already
available to medicaid participants in
the state of new hampshire there are
three managed care organizations
operating in the state
one of those three mcos amir health
caritas
offers dental benefits as part of its
package
and i can quote from their
materials adult members age 28 21 and
older are covered for a range of dental
services including preventive services
cleanings diagnostic services exams and
x-rays restorative services fillings
and some periodontal services root
planing and scaling the new hampshire
department of health and human services
currently covers extractions under a
separate program
so the fact is that medicaid
participants in new hampshire already
have access to dental care
if they want it
what this plan would do
would be to extend benefits to people
who for whatever reason
have decided to go with one of the two
other mcos that do not provide dental
benefits
so this bill is unnecessary
this program will grow it will become
more expensive this is a new entitlement
and we need only to look to a history of
other entitlements and their growth
trajectory
the medicaid program when it was
established in 1965 was projected to
cost 238 million dollars in the first
year at a federal level
actual costs were over four times that
at a billion dollars
if i take that 238 million dollar
estimate and i fast forward adjust for
inflation to 2019
then theoretically we should have had a
cost
at the federal level
of 1.9 billion dollars
actual federal outlays
were 380 billion dollars
so about 200 times
that estimate going back to uh to the
founding of the program
that doesn't include state outlays
and although this is one example there
are many if you go looking for examples
of programs that ended up costing
significantly more than they were
projected to cost there are plenty of
them out there
so this is one example and they're
federal numbers but it illustrates a
common theme
estimates for entitlements including
medicare and medicaid are historically
wrong
in fact they are historically very wrong
and they always seem to be wrong
in the same direction
benefits will grow under this program
in fact the language of the amendment is
written
to include
among other things behavior management
and smoking cessation counseling
and other services
as determined by the commission
commissioner
so will this program expand in fact this
bill is an expansion of an entitlement
program with further expansion
capabilities written in
this will be permanent
there is no sunset provision in this
bill
once we do this we all know
that it is virtually impossible to
rescind a program like this
and why might we want to rescind it we
might want to rescind it if it's not
living up to its promises
that leads to my fourth point
there is not an adequate structure for
accountability in this bill
the bill does contain language that call
for the dhhs to present an annual report
which includes among other things
indicators of program effectiveness
well how are we defining program
effectiveness because the proponents of
this bill have said that one of its key
selling points is that it's going to
save
a lot of money because people who are
getting adequate dental care down the
road are not going to have as many
emergency room visits they're not going
to have as many hospital stays and
they're not going to have as many
surgeries
i acknowledge that there is some truth
to that good dental hygiene does
contribute to good health and could save
money down the road i question whether
it is as big a cost savings as the
proponents of this bill
would put forward
nobody has said what that number is
nor have they said how it would be
measured
probably because it is virtually
impossible to measure
all the costs that didn't happen because
you rolled out a program like this
so if one of the most important selling
points of this bill if not the most
important selling point of this bill is
something that is virtually impossible
to measure
then i question whether we can ever know
if this program
is effective and has achieved its
intended results
so in summary this bill is not necessary
medicaid participants who want dental
care can already get it it will grow
there is no sunset provision it will be
permanent
and it lacks an adequate accountability
structure
to assure taxpayers that is delivering
on the promises that its proponents have
touted so strongly i urge my colleagues
to press the red button
and vote against the otpa recommendation
so that an alternate motion can be made
and mr speaker i am asking for a roll
call vote does the member yield to
questions
i do not remember does not yield
the chair recognizes representative mark
pearson
to speak in favor committee report
thank you mr speaker
this bill as amended
is a result of a lot of hard work
by a bipartisan subgroup of the health
human services and elderly affairs
committee
who considered the costs in some depth
and compared with what other states are
doing
in terms of dental care including red
states
i charged them to produce
a bill that would not be a handout to
the greedy but a hand up to the truly
needy
it would demand some accountability and
co-responsibility
from those receiving our help
but would also recognize there are truly
needy people
who without are helping them obtain
preventative dental care
will contract such dental problems as to
require very expensive care on the
taxpayer's dime
i am part-time ceo of a medical center
in kingston
we regularly see people who have
deferred much too long the care they
need
with the result of their needing
expensive care
we often provide reduced cost care to
those people who cannot afford it
various plans notwithstanding
while we know there are people who try
to game us and we watch for that
most of us
most of those asking our help truly need
it
and in this time of inflation
especially so
but we as a small facility can only do
so much
and we recognize there are many more
people who need help
i believe our bipartisan work group did
their job well
and so we have before it's a bill that
provides a hand up and not a handout
that requires recipients of our help to
share in responsibility
and that will keep people from those
expensive expensive treatments that will
cost the taxpayers a lot of money
i asked the legislature to support this
bill which had nearly unanimous
bipartisan support
in committee
thank you mr speaker remember yield to
questions
member yields you may require
thank you for taking my question i i
just want to
make sure that we're all voting with
absolute clarity there was a statement
that sounded like fact
by the other speaker who said that the
adult dental medicaid benefit
already existed
and i just want to make sure my
understanding of that is is correct i is
it true
that the one mco of the three that
provides it
does it strictly on a voluntary
charitable basis
and can change their policy at any time
because it is their charity and they're
spending the small 1.5 profit margin on
providing this uh charitable care is
that is that true
that is what our that is what our
research uncovered yes it is true
mr speaker will the member yield to a
further question
remember does not yield
we have a request for roll calls that's
officially seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
[Applause]
[Music]
so
six
it's a roll call vote on house bill 103
majority report ought to pass as amended
chair recognizes
representative peter pearson for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i knew that this bill is the result
of a bipartisan work group
that worked long and hard to articulate
a balanced approach
and if i knew that preventative care
often forced stalls
far more expensive care down the road
and if i knew that this bill gives a
hand up not a handout
and if i knew that this bill required
shared responsibility
and finally if i knew that this
bill as amended had near unanimous
support in committee bipartisanly so
would i not press the green button
thank you mr speaker
the question is on house bill 103 in the
majority report of what a pass has
amended this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative conley
representative cannon
representative melvin
representative rice
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
225 voting yay 127 voting a committee
report is adopted
and is referred to the committee on
finance mr speaker
who
mr speaker
where are you
representative marsh at a1 okay
mr speaker i have a question of the
chair
i would like to know if
the intention of the chair in sending
out the rapid covet test
uh a short time before this meeting was
that members who tested positive should
remain home
and i have a follow-up question
that was the intention
uh thank you mr speaker
since that was your intention and since
i have reason to believe that there is
at least one member in this chamber who
tested positive and is present in the
room i would like to know if it would be
in order to move reconsideration of the
change in house rules
permitting remote participation at this
time
house will be in order
mr speaker
first off i i have
no concrete evidence that somebody has
tested positive in this room mr speaker
uh on d2 oh i'm sorry will the
representative yield to a weight
of the chair it's a question of the
chair uh
i'm asking if the representative will
yield to a question
that's not
how we do things when he's questioning
me okay thank you i'm sorry
mr speaker
well let me finish with this
representative please
i have no evidence that anybody has
tested positive
i have i have no evidence
if someone brings forth evidence they
may very well do that thank you very
much
mr speaker for what members are foreign
it's in relation to the previous uh
question
i'd like to know mr speaker and maybe
you would too
if the evidence involves listening to
conversation and conversations in the
ladies room
i know that sounds like a strange
question but it's relevant i promise
as of this
as at this point
i have no evidence that anybody has
tested positive
if there is somebody in this room that
has tested positive
i say right now
bluntly get out you shouldn't be here
we sent those test kits out
we sent those test kits out for a reason
and that's why we sent them out so if
you were feeling sick
or you had any reason to believe you
would use them
and not show up at this meeting
we've done a lot to try and make sure
everybody is safe as possible
and we're going to continue to try and
do that
and if anybody and i'll say it again if
anybody
knows they tested positive
get out
i mean that sincerely get out now and
you shouldn't be here
mr mr speaker
uh representative soundsuch a1
yes i have a motion
i have a motion mr speaker
what is your motion sir
uh mr mr speaker i would like to ask you
to allow a minute of silence to remember
the victims of january 6 and the attack
on our national capital
and our democracy
thank you mr speaker
house will be in order
that is a motion that i will take up at
the end of session
i believe it is out of order right now
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 359
enact creating a private cause of action
for discrimination based on hair styles
relative to a person's authenticity
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
representative mark mclean for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment
representative alexis simpson for the
minority of the committee mr speaker
c3
yes
mr speaker i'd like to make a motion to
table hp 359
motion is in order
the motion before us is the table house
bill 359
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and 359 is laid on the
table
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 478
an act relative to treatment of pfas
contaminants in the drinking water of
merrimack village water district having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution
being resolved resolved that it's
inexpedient to legislate representative
mark mclean from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass
the chair recognizes
representative
boyd
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker and through you to
my esteemed colleagues of the general
court
i rise to speak in favor of house bill
478 which makes san gobain
paid for the damage that they have done
had san gobain followed what they had
previously done with other communities
such as sousa falls
we would not be here today discussing
this issue
communities like
merrimack bedford londonderry and
litchfield have been fighting for
justice from this polluter since 2016.
these communities are just asking
sangobain to do the right thing
and supply clean potable water
not only to our constituents but to the
businesses that use these communities as
their place of operations
water
that san gobain has readily admit they
polluted
that being a good corporate citizen
involves fighting towns
fighting the state and even the federal
government every step of the way
in 2016 sangoman first self-reported
that the water in their plant had tested
positive for the cancer-causing
substance known as pfas
i would ask you mr speaker
how many companies test
the public drinking water for a
substance that they readily use in their
operations
i would suggest that a company
that previously had contaminated
drinking water
in communities in houston falls new york
and bennington vermont is one thank you
the town of merrimack the state reps in
the affected areas in the local water
supplier
merrimack village water district entered
into discussions to work on remediation
at the time
the limits on these chemicals in the
drinking water were not highly regulated
and most of them were in the 100s parts
per trillion
mr speaker
it's getting very loud
since he stopped talking it's quieted
down
remember may continue
thank you mr speaker
at the time the limits on these
chemicals in the drinking water were not
highly regulated and most of them were
in the 100 parts per trillion
the town of merrimack and its citizens
created a citizen advocate group started
extensive research on these chemicals
and what they can do not only to the
human body
but to developing fetuses and even our
pets
they then ask then senator kelly ayotte
to intervene with the epa
to expedite the adoption of its pending
public health advisory level for pfas
in late 2016 the epa finalized its
current public health advisory
at the combined level of 70 parts per
trillion
some of the measurements coming out of
the water around san gobain
the merrimack plant at that time
were anywhere from 3 300 parts per train
in november of 2018
to a high of 69
500 parts per trillion in may of 2019.
all of these test numbers in and around
the plant were far in excess of these
new set limits
the new hampshire legislature following
the leadership of the late speaker dick
hench
acted when he stated
it was obvious that without something
being done
to san gobain they would continue to do
business as usual based on their actions
to that point
new hampshire house bill 1766 a
bipartisan bill was signed into law
in june 2018 requiring the department of
environmental services to start testing
for pfos
chemicals at the seacoast and other
landfills
new hampshire senate bill 309 was then
signed into law in july of 2018 which
regulated pfas and groundwater and
drinking water pollution
in september of 2019
a bipartisan bill new hampshire senate
bill 193 in new hampshire senate bill
257 were signed into law prohibiting
pfas chemicals in firefighter foams
furniture and carpeting
based on these bills in june 2019
department of environmental services
announced a new maximum contaminant
level in public drinking water for four
major pfos chemicals studied at that
time
with the announcement of the new levels
all
merrimack village district wells tested
above these limits
and the merrimack village district had
had to add redundant filtration systems
to meet these new levels which increased
the cost of filtration already approved
by mbd customers
merrimack village district continued
negotiating with san gobain on doing
something
anything about the wells that they had
immediately polluted
san gobain did finally agree
to filter the two wells that they had
agreed
were inside the consent decree area but
they only agreed to fill to provide five
years worth of maintenance of filters in
the filter media to treat the water
seeing that the half-life of these
chemicals is 100 years
the town of merrimack and
the ratepayers that participate in the
merrimack village district are looking
at about 300 years or so for the water
to no longer to be required to be
filtered
this leads the merrimack ratepayer on
the hook
for the ongoing ongoing maintenance for
an issue that they were not responsible
for now going decades into the future
conversely in relation to hoosick falls
the agreement that san gobain signed
with hoosick falls
is that they will pay for filtration
in perpetuity
which makes you ponder from me mr
speaker looking back in 2016
what would cause san gobain to
self-report the polluted water
was it so knowing that if san gobain
acted in this in this manner they could
get a town in citizenry
who are now worrying about safe drinking
water
to rush to judgment and panic just to
get things done
i would surmise they were
mr speaker
i urge my colleagues to override the
committee recommendation to itl
and to enter and permit a new motion of
octopass
the times of merrimack and bedford and
its citizens who draw water from the
merrimack village district deserve
nothing less than safe clean portable
drinking water for years and generations
to come thank you mr speaker remember
yield the questions i'd be more than
happy to remember yields
is it true
that saint gobain
agreed to put
a filter
in their system
say so they would no longer pollute
and is it true
that they agreed to do this
and they did install the filter but it
came with a bypass
that went around the filter is all of
that true
mr speaker the short answer is no
the issue that my distinguished
gentleman is referring to is referring
to the return regenerative thermal
oxidizer which is the clean clean fast
going into the air is a specifically
different issue as it relates to
filtration of water mr speaker
follow-up further question do you
remember yield to another question i'd
be happy to i have a question
a1
are they continuing
to put pfast
into the air
as long as the rto is working the answer
is no if the rto is not working the
answer would be yes
thank you
question question of the
a1
does the member yield a further question
i'd be happy to mr speaker main guy
would you believe that the epa
is considering
making
lowering the standards even more to no
detect
for pfoa and pfas
yes
mr speaker
i'm at 8-2
uh may i ask a question of the
representative does the member yield to
a further question for the distinguished
gentlelady yes
you may inquire thank you
if this bill is iit is if the itl fails
and another motion that it ought to pass
is successful
would that discourage other polluters
from passing on the cost of cleanup
to taxpayers and other ratepayers i
would hope so
the short answer is yes
thank you
chair recognizes representative langley
to speak against committee report
thank you mr speaker
the environmental agreement addressing
the groundwater contamination between
the town of merrimack new hampshire and
saint gomez is flawed
flawed because the groundwater
contamination described has spread and
it has continued long past the time
period
cited for the original agreement
i'm sorry
oh my god
to think the initial agreement was valid
under such circumstances would need to
assume that the groundwater is static
and the p-fast in the soil has magically
stopped leaching
though it has manufacturing operations
zinc domains contaminated groundwater
with toxic pfas
including the wells of the merrimack
municipal water provider merrimack
village district
house bill 478 would require saint gomez
to take full financial responsibility
for installing
and maintaining filtration systems for
two of the directly impacted mvd wells
and that would ensure the water meets
the new hampshire drinking water
standards for pfas
currently mvd rate payers are bearing
the cost that should be the sole
responsibility of the polluter
the town of merrimack's agreement with
saint germain
focused on the short term need of well
contamination
but remediation is now anticipated to be
longer term as pfas resists degradation
in the environment
pfas particles are bio-accumulative
with life's
half-lifes of up to nine years assuming
further contamination is does not occur
recently the department of health and
human services released a report that
cited higher than expected numbers of
merrimack residents suffered from kidney
and renal cancer
the state of new hampshire has a moral
obligation to ensure polluters are held
responsible no matter how short-sighted
the initial agreement was
we therefore request you vote itl so a
new motion can be brought forward thank
you mr speaker mr speaker
mr speaker
where where is the point of order here
microphone
a
one can i say that
what is
what is your point of order the noise
level mr speaker has risen
to really unacceptable levels you've
been very good about trying to keep it
down but it's gotten out of control
again thank you
speaker speaker
i have
for the last day and a half
asked
that people respect
a member when they're speaking and i can
tell you that the noise level is coming
from both sides not just one side
i don't know how many times i've got to
ask members to be respectful and keep
the noise limit down and i'll keep
trying but that's the best i can do
representative
mr speaker
may i repeat the last sentence because
i'm not sure it was
where are we
who is speaking please e1 representative
langley
a3 i'm sorry
we therefore request you vote against
the itl
so that a new motion can be brought
forward thank you
mr speaker d2
yes
mr speaker i would politely ask you that
a roll ball call
roll call vote be taken on this matter
uh i kind of expected that thank you mr
speaker okay
the chair calls representative mclean
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i'm here
to speak in support of the committee
recommendation of itl on hb 478 which
requires that cinco bain performance
plastics pay for the remediation of
water in certain wells contaminated with
pfas
the majority of the committee understood
why the people of merrimack would feel
aggrieved by the actions of saint gobain
and they also agreed that the current
well maintenance agreement which ends in
may be inadequate in light of
information gained since the agreement
was entered into however
the committee also felt that asking the
legislature to extend the agreement for
as long as treatment is necessary sets a
precedent that the legislature should
avoid
past legislative proposals which
addressed clean up remediation
medical monitoring and other issues
related to pfas on a broad basis
this bill seeks to have the legislature
judgment in a specific case
the committee felt that this should be
left to the courts
the courts could review any new
information there could be a discovery
process on both sides could prevent data
to support their respective positions
and a decision as to whether or not to
modify the agreement could be brought
forward
in light of all that they've had to
endure the people of merrimack are more
than justified in their desire to review
the terms of the current agreement
the courts
are well positioned to do this kind of
work the legislature is not
i hope you'll join me in supporting the
bipartisan majority position of itl on
hb 478 thank you mr speaker
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take their seats
from
so
members take your seats so we can move
along
so
the question before us
is the
motion of itl the majority emotion of
itl on house bill 478 this is going to
be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
mayville for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know
that i feel like erin brockovich
and if i know that several communities
and many taxpayers in hillsborough
county have been subject to the worst
drinking water pollution in the history
of the state
and unless we hold this company
accountable for their actions this
travis email what may well come
to another town and another county
and if i further know
that new hampshire taxpayers
will ultimately be subjected to a
horrendous financial impact due to a
private company willfully and
negligently polluting
and continuing to pollute our state's
air
soil and groundwater
and lastly if i know
that options for litigation have been
exhausted and we bring the case to the
general court of new hampshire with the
sole purpose of protecting our state
its communities and taxpayers our
children and our grandchildren
then mr speaker
would i press the red button to
respectfully overturn the committee
report of itl in order to enter a new
motion on this legislation
the chair recognizes representative
gordon for a parliamentary empire
thank you
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the
judiciary committee does care deeply
about the people who are affected by the
pollution caused by saint gobain
but if i also know
that
the merrimack
village water district entered into a
contract
to settle come to settle its claims back
in 2018
and
if
if i know
that there may be
good reason why people would feel that
that was a mistake
or it wasn't a proper contract at the
time
and i know that the way contracts are
normally voided
is by
going to court
when a contract is fraudulent or created
by
mutual misrepresentation or mutual
misunderstanding
or it's simply unconscionable
but the remedy for avoiding a contract
is not typically going to the
legislature to avoid a contract which is
what this legislation effectively
attempts to do
the remedy is ordinarily to go to court
to do that which i understand
is currently in progress
and i think i would ask if and i
and if i know
that
in terms of process the better approach
in this case as the majority of the
committee bipartisan majority of the
committee felt was to
litigate this in court to determine
whether or not the contract was valid
before
the legislature acting to avoid it
and if that was the case would i press
the green button mr speaker
question before us on house bill 478 is
the majority report of inexpedient to
legislate
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
represent font now
representative herbert
representative highland
representative mcconkey
represent perez
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the boat
139 voting a 212 voting nay
the motion fails mr speaker
d2
why does the member rise
i'd like to make a motion of ought to
pass state your motion ought to pass
the motion before us is ought to pass
on house bill 478
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
the eyes have it
an emotion
is adopted
if all members will stay in their seats
we've got a division coming up with just
parliamentary inquiries after i'm done
reading
majority committee on judiciary to which
was referred house bill
5797 fn act relative to the expectation
of privacy having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
representative kurt walper for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator joe
alexander from the minority of the
committee
the amendment is 2164-h printing and
house record 48 pages 99 through 100 are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
this is a division vote
this is mr speaker i'm at a microphone
c3
i'm okay with waving pi too
okay we don't we can just go to voice
vote too i don't care
um
the question is on otpa
represent representative smith are you
waving your
pi he
he waved his
the question before us is on house bill
majority report about the past has
amended are ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
oh yeah
majority of the committee on judiciary
jewish was referred house bill 622 fn
enact protecting nascent human life as a
reasonable and valid state interest
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendations the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator marjorie
smith with the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative kurt walper for
the minority of the committee
chair recognizes
representative stephen smith
uh thank you mr speaker i moved to lay
house bill 622 on the table
the motion is to lay house bill 622 on
the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
[Music]
[Applause]
please a division has been called for
division
members take your seats there has been a
call for a division vote
okay
this is a
this is a vision vote on the
tabling motion on 622 the chair
recognizes representative stephen smith
for parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i have outstanding
questions about the bill itself and the
various amendments and would like time
to dig into all that would i get that
time by pressing the green button
chair recognizes representative marjorie
smith
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know
that the speaker has had this fill
since
early november
and if i know that it was not until
minutes from now before now that a
question was raised about the
appropriateness of the committee
amendment
and if i know that we were given no
opportunity to explore this matter in a
responsible way that follows appropriate
legislative procedure
would i now with great pain and sadness
support the tabling motion
the question before us
is on house bill 622
the tabling motion of house bill 622
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you will press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative alicea
thank you
represent cretian
representative guthrie
so
representative moran are you here
representative tausch
no it's a division
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
state
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
325 voting a
23 voting nay
622 is laid on the table
foreign
majority of the committee on labor
industrial and real data services which
was referred house bill 517 fn in act
relative to the
state minimum hourly rate having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpensive to legislate president of
leonard church for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator brian sullivan for the
majority of the committee
mr speaker
state your point of order um
this is literally a point of order there
was still one more judiciary bill that
was on the calendar before we went ahead
to the labor bills
unless i'm let's just something happen
that i don't know about but
i personally have no objection to
continuing with this one and then
getting back to it later but
5.97
we've dealt with all the bills on a
regular calendar
oh all right thank you
chair recognizes uh representative
seaworth
for what reason remember rise
thank you mr speaker i'd like to make a
motion
stage of motion i move to table
hb 517
seaworth moves the table house bill 517.
are you ready for the question division
the division has been called for members
take your seats this will be a division
vote
division
[Music]
the motion before us is tabling of five
bill 517.
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
sullivan for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker i'd sign up with the clerk
sorry my mistake representative chair
recognized representative for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that a vote to table a good minimum wage
is a vote on behalf of the privileged
few and the high hats of society and not
the common everyday person
if i also be in order
if i know that time after time when
voters go to the polls where a minimum
wage is on the ballot it is the most
popular item on the ballot even in
republican states like missouri and
florida
if i know that i agree with former
president trump who on the campaign
trail in 2016 said quote the minimum
wage has to go up at least 10 federally
but it has to go up
if i know
that we can't find enough lnas or
grocery store clerks because we expect
them to work for starvation wages and
oddly enough nobody likes that deal
if i know that the working poor who were
oh so thrilled to find themselves deemed
by governments as essential workers have
so far only received genuflected
facebook posts from the permanent
managerial class in the financial elite
instead of the raise they have more than
earned
and if i know that opponents of a good
minimum wage say that it takes a
person's or what takes away a person's
self-reliance but what really kills
someone's self-reliance is having to
work 60 hours a week for 7.25 eight
dollars an hour or ten dollars an hour
would i now press the red button to vote
on this extremely important bill jerrick
jerrick
okay the chair recognizes representative
turcotte for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know most entry level
wages in new hampshire already exceed
the minimum wage hikes proposed in this
bill
and if i further know many minimum wage
bills have been defeated in this chamber
multiple times in the last several house
sessions
and finally mr speaker if i know that
the economic law of supply and demand
working in conjunction with the free
market principles will always determine
a fair market wage
would i now press the green button to
table hb 517. thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 517 this division
vote you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative chiller
representative mayville
representative oxel
representative peterson
representative rose
that was peterson not pearson
[Music]
austin
the wall members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
under 91 voting yay 158 voting a house
bill 517 is laid on the table
i want everybody to
know where we're
where we're set we've got 21 bills left
we're going at a decent pace
if it's all possible and
both sides agree to cooperate
we should be able to finish up tonight
at a very reasonable hour
that will come with total cooperation
if not
um
then we'd have to come back tomorrow
and the snowstorm is
not looking like it's something that we
want to bring you back in so if
everybody
plays nice
then let's see if we can get through
these next 21 bills in a reasonable time
there's no debate on this amendment
all right
the committee on labor industrial and
rehabilitative services to which was
referred house bill 589 fn
an act requiring workers compensation to
cover prophylactic treatment for
critical exposure
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
michael cahill for the committee
the amendment is 2131
house record 48
page 99
the question is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on
the committee report of ought to pass
with amendment this will be a division
vote members please take your seats
[Music]
okay
thank you
the question is on the committee report
of ought to pass with amendment if
you're in favor of the report you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative abramson representative
all chiller
representative burroughs
representative
representative grota
representative levesque
representative lockman representative
perez
representative post
representative
representative woodcock representative
bill boyd
your good representative posts
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
211 having voted in the affirmative 133
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
legislative administration which was
referred to house bill 558 an act
establishing a committee to study the
use of information technology in the
legislative process having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
matthew simon for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative timothy
smith for the minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report of expedient to
legislate this is a division vote
members please take your seats mr
speaker
for what reason does it memorize
i like to make a motion
i'm a d2
yeah i've already put the question
i can't make a motion
not at this time now
the question is on itl
the the questions on an expedient to
legislate right now
who's gotta be
okay
all right this is a division vote
representative tim smith is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that yesterday you
yourself
informed the members of the body that we
should not and could not support a rule
change
for remote participation without seeing
a detailed proposal on how to do that
and if i know that this committee
would be the committee to produce the
report that you yourself identified we
need
and if i further know that an ad hoc
committee as some have suggested would
have no official standing no power or
ability at all to produce any sort of an
official plan for the house to consider
and that this is a study committee in
this bill is the only way
to produce the report that you yourself
mr speaker identified we need when i
push the red button so that another
motion can be made thank you
representative green is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know this body heard this exact
bill last term
and if i know
we have more than enough study
committees
and tabling this bill would not prevent
a rep from advocating for new technology
with the facilities committee or ceo and
staff
then would i press the red button thank
you mr speaker
you sure about that
the green button good thing you asked
the question before the house is on the
majority committee report of an
expedient to legislate if you're in
favor you will be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
representative reed
representative shapiro
representative schamberg
representative marsh
representative lawton
representative delemus
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
183 having voted in the affirmative 162
and the negative the committee report is
adopted
the committee on public works and
highways to which was referred to house
bill 122 a an act making an
appropriation to the carroll and
stratford county's freight rail
improvements project and making an
appropriation for the coast county
freight rail improvement project having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative bill
boyd for the committee
the amendment is 2128
on
in house record 48 on pages 80-81
representative graham is recognized
thank you mr speaker mr speaker there
has been some erroneous information
circulated about what this bill does i
ask that you one read the committee
report and see what it says two
look at
the amendment
the amendment changes everything to
include the title of the bill
it now deals with a separation in the
capital budget between a federally
funded aviation hangar
and a state-funded aviation hangar for
the police
helicopter safe police helicopter it
does not change a single appropriation
that we passed in house bill 25 as far
as dollar amounts there was changes in
the federal funding and federal rules
but we need to get the money separated
between federal and state so that we can
continue with the work for the police
please vote for the amendment and then
vote to pass as amended i just wanted to
clarify that it no longer deals with
railroads thank you
thank you the question is on the
committee amendment are you ready for
the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
now the question before the house is the
majority committee report of octopass
with amendment are you ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the majority of the committee on
resources recreation and development to
which was referred house bill 571 an act
repealing the prohibition against ohrvi
travel on hoyt road marsh
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative andrew
renzulo for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative suzanne smith for the
minority of the committee
the member from hebron representative
suzanne smith is recognized to speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker i'm here at a1
i rise today in opposition of the ought
to pass motion on house bill 571
white road marsh is a 101 acre marsh
with an adjacent upland managed by the
fish and game department as a wildlife
management area
it has a diversity of habitat types the
upland habitat surrounding the marshes
forest
the wetland the marsh
is itself has numerous wetland dependent
species that live in the marsh year
round including beaver otter and muskrat
the upland surrounding the marsh is home
to deer black bear coyote and the
occasional moose and seasonally a number
of bird species breed and feed on the
property
during the winter of 2018-19
the city of concord received numerous
complaints from neighbors about the
disruption caused by motorcycles riding
on a plowed area of the frozen marsh
racing around sometimes at speeds of 50
to 60 miles per hour
there were so many complaints about
noise traffic and waste issues that the
city tried to address these issues
through local regulations
this failed because although it is a
very shallow marsh the acreage of hoyt
road marsh put it under state
jurisdiction
what were the people whose home life was
disrupted and the city do they were
faced with cleanup and traffic
violations when all else fails citizens
come to us their legislature to find
solutions
bill filing deadlines have passed so the
prohibition of ohrvis on white road
marsh was inserted into the budget
trailer bill in 2019
this bill was passed by the legislature
and signed by our current governor
it has now been three winters since the
prohibition became law
during the public hearing the committee
heard from numerous neighbors thankful
that they could now enjoy peace in their
homes the loud noise of revving engines
gone
we also heard that the repeal is needed
by those who want their children to be
able to ride at high speeds on
motorcycles with studded tires on the
frozen marsh
and it isn't just the noise of the
motorcycles that the minority of the
committee residents and the people who
drive white road find problematic point
road is narrow and parking used to
access the marsh is very limited just
picture five to ten vehicles pulling
trailers with their motorcycles as well
as cars of people who have come to enjoy
the spectacle
cramming into a small parking lot or
along the road add to that that there
are no facilities there are no porta
potties no trash receptacles
not a pretty picture
i asked fish and game officials whose
responsibility
whose responsibility the marsh area is
if the agency would be providing porta
potties if the repeal is lifted no way
that will be the responsibility of the
city of concord the city which has no
say in whether ice riding be allowed
it should be noted that there are
alternatives to white road marsh for ice
racing a number of ponds in concord and
the lakes region do allow it
turtle town pond only a couple of miles
from hoyt road marsh is one of them
folks who want to ice ride can easily
travel there or to two or three other
ponds within 10 to 20 miles where ice
racing is allowed
point road marsh is a valuable wetland
and upland noted for diversity of
species both flora and fauna and there
are other options nearby so i ask you to
vote against repealing ohrv prohibition
by pushing the red button so that
another motion may be made and thank you
thank you the member from hudson
representative renzullo is recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
thank you miss thank you mr speaker can
you hear me
i'd rather speak to the folks out here i
don't wish to speak to the uh
you find my back
is that
is it required to speak to the speaker
or is it can i speak to the members
actually never speak to the body except
when they're answering a question i
believe so i know it's awkward all right
well then i'll guess i will follow your
directions
can you still hear me out there
okay
let's start off with some basic facts mr
speaker
for lakes over 10 acres
water
liquid and ice is owned the water is
owned by the state
for the benefit of all the people
that means that you
me every resident who does not own
property on said lakes has the same
right to recreate on those lakes winter
and summer
the same right as someone who does own
lakes own land bordering
the lakes
this bill repeals the prohibition which
became law in 2019
against the ohrvis which off highway
recreational vehicles traveling on hoyt
road marsh which is a lake that exceeds
10 acres in the city of concord
prior to the ban the local residents
complained of the noise and
environmental effect the riders
testified they were on a large pond
surrounded by trees and were re
recreating legally on public ice they
testified that they were always
respectful to the residents and they
took care to avoid conflicts
the residents disagreed
with all the conflicting testimony you
would think that prior to enacting the
2019 ban a site visit would have been
done by some committee
before a ban was passed
and before it became law let's check the
committee record let's look at the file
but there is no record
there is no file there was no site visit
there was no hearing there was no
committee there was no bill
but amazingly
as if by magic
and written by the fiery finger of
divine entity
in
the house bill 2 the trailer bill there
appeared item
291 which was which
i quote
ohrvs shall prohibit from traveling on
hoyt road marsh in the city of concord
unquote
that's it
no bill
no notice no hearing
is that due process
one line
slipped into a hundred and thirty three
or thirty three page bill was all it
took
a site visit now
by the present committee
hearing this that heard this appeal
would be useless
the statue enacted the term enacted the
term before
forced the activity of the writers to
cease
so
there was nothing to see
nothing to hear it was like the body had
been cremated before the coroner had a
chance to examine it
there's probably not too many people
here
who remember the
1948 movie the treasure of sierra madre
there was a famous quote where humphrey
bogart
character called the humphrey bogart
character asked to see the badges of the
bandits
who clue who claimed to be federal
police
the bandit leader responds badges
we don't need no stinking badges
hearings we don't need no stinking
hearings bills we don't need no bills
notice
we don't need no
rules for thee
not
for me
but
since we cannot say anything negative
about anyone and to keep the peace in
the valley
let us suffice to say that something
unique
maybe even miraculous
no notified bishop about that something
even miraculous happened in house bill 2
in 2019
but even if you believe the procedural
irregularities
which by whether by intent or divine
intervention aren't enough to justify
the committee's recommendation of ought
to pass in other words repealing the ban
the present
house
house resources recreation and
development committee
still
had sufficient credible evidence from a
reputable source to reach a decision
the pond and much of its environs is
under the
control of the new hampshire fish and
game department the department testimony
to the resources committee favored the
position of the riders they had purse
they had
processed some complaints from abutters
prior to the ban and came down on the
side of the riders they also testified
that no outright bans like this exist in
this state
except this one passed in 2019.
there are two paths that bring the
committee to the same result
one way is evidentiary
we have two adversarial parties each
presenting conflicting testimony in a
court of law the testimony of a neutral
party or known trusted entity
like the department of fish and game
would carry considerable weight
it is also
that alone is sufficient to pass this
bill and repeal the ban
the other path is more complicated
regardless of how we got there the
statute was created without public input
a group of people lost a right without
any knowledge or chance to defend
themselves
isn't
in the physical conflict isn't that the
definition of a sucker punch
what point at what point does expediency
trump procedure at what point do our
rules and procedures cease to be in
violent and become suggestions
mr speaker our strength is that we are
400 plain ordinary citizens making a
hundred bucks a year
the only thing of value we get is our
self-respect
and our integrity
when you press the green button you will
be in fact be pressing the reset button
all parties will go back to their status
before the statute of 2019 was passed
all would be made whole again it is then
that the writers and abutters will have
equal access to the system of government
and justice all expect and when they ask
that we show them our badges we can
proudly show them our badges and assure
them that we stand ready to serve them
in the best of our ability with firmness
in the right that god gives us the right
to see that right
thank you mr speaker
the house will be in order
[Applause]
does the member yield to a question
doesn't look like it sorry
well then
the question before the house is the
majority committee report of ought to
pass are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
somebody requested a division this will
be a division vote members please take
your seats
division
okay the question is on the majority
committee report of
ought to pass on house bill
where we go 571
representative shirtless is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know the repeal and the prohibition
on ohiv's on the marsh will lead to
traffic ingestion noise trash
and waste accumulation an area making
passive recreation
less enjoyable and almost impossible
and mr speaker if i know that during the
three winters since the prohibition was
signed into law
that those who enjoyed the sport of
racing motorcycles on ice have found
other opportunities on ponds in both
cronkite and the lakes region
and mr speaker if i know
that one of my greatest memories from
being born and raised in the city of
concord
was spending summers with my dad fishing
for han powder on the banks
of the hoyt marsh
and it would break my heart to see
that marsh just boiled
as it was in the past
would i now push the red button so
another motion could be brought forward
thank you mr speaker
representative walsh is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that bodies of water over 10
acres are state-owned public resources
if i believe
the rights of landowners who abut these
resources do not outweigh the rights of
the general public that use them
if i know that the new hampshire fish
and game department who also supports
this bill has never had to issue a
violation to any of the ohiv riders on
hoyt road marsh
and finally mr speaker if i know the
current prohibition on ohrvis has all
the signs of political favor for a
special interest would i now press the
green button
this house will be in order this is a
division vote if you're in favor of the
majority committee report you'll press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so much food
representatives speak to you
there we go thank you
represent roy you're all set
represent long
representative harriet gathright
thank you
represent man
representative levesque
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
189 having voted in the affirmative 158
and the negative the committee reports
adopted
the majority of the committee on
resources recreation and development
which was referred house bill 611 fn
an act abolishing fluoridation and water
have been considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
lisa post for the majority of the
committee
the committee amendment is 1392
on in house record 48 on page 106.
the minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
chuck grassy or the
minority of the committee
the question is on the committee
amendment one three nine two h
for what reason doesn't memorize
mr speaker i'd like to recommend that hb
611 be laid on the table
representative grassy moves that house
bill 611 be laid on the table
this will be a division
who requested a roll call
representative sylvia requests a roll
call and it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
please take your seats
everybody was still here
all right thousand come to order
representative grass is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that over 300 new
hampshire dental professionals oppose
this bill and have said that is the bill
is dangerous
and i also know that the bill would add
over two million dollars per year
for supplement support to hb103 that we
just recently passed
and in addition medical costs
additional medical costs and even
greater in unknown hospital costs for
the treatment of decay
pain infections as well as increased
treatment
and if i lastly know that this is a bill
of local concern
and local option
when i press the green button
representative renzo is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that 1950 is calling and they
want their fluoridation procedure back
so they can put it in a museum
and if i know that modern
fluoridation treatments done in in by in
the offices of dentists are far safer
effective and more controllable than
haphazardly dumping a known toxic
chemical into the water supply and if i
know that spending that we will spend
millions of dollars fighting fluorinated
hydrocarbons in our water yet
deliberately add toxic fluoride salt to
our drinking water
and finally no not finally what and i
know if
if i know that this bill
has been jacked around for two years
being tabled on a covet all-nighter
being retained because of time
constraints and now a tabling attempt
again
with the bill coming out of committee
with bro each time with broad bipartisan
support
and finally
if i know that this bill carries on
the last the
the last term tabled bill
put forward by the late representative
dick marple
who passed away before he could refile
this bill and it pres and he did it
deserves
the respect
of a debate and an up or down vote
then
may i was asked that we press the red
button thank you
the question is on whether to lay house
bill 611 on the table if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
representative roy
representative roy if you could just
step a little closer
representative stavis are you still here
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 having voted the affirmative 162 on
the negative the committee report is
adopted
my bad i apologize
house bill 611 is laid on the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred to house bill 153 an act
establishing a committee to study
universal internet access for new
hampshire having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it has in
expediency legislate representative
michael voss from the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative lee oxenham for the
minority of the committee
what reason does the member rise
a3
mr speaker i move that house bill 153 be
laid upon the table representative vos
moves that house bill 153 be laid on the
table division
a division vote's been requested this
will be a division vote members please
take your seats
[Music]
is there a
is there a pi over there
mr speaker i have a pi at a1
a1 okay who's that
got it
what's up
representative mental is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr face mr speaker
if i know that universal high-speed
internet access
is as important today
as rural electrification
was 90 years ago and if i know the
universal high-speed internet access is
critical to leveling the playing field
for students and businesses throughout
the state and if i know that this bill
establishes a committee to study the
best ways to implement that access
would i press the red button and vote no
so a new motion can be made
representative is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this legislature is awash in
study committees and commissions
and if i know that the issue of
broadband expansion has been studied by
at least a half a dozen committees in
the last
15 years
and finally mr speaker
if i know that this is a well understood
issue
and that the federal government is
supplying
a lot of money
for broadband expansion in new hampshire
as well as the rest of the country
would i press the
green button to lay this
bill on the table
the question is on whether to lay house
bill 153 on the table if you are in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
yes
representative mcgee
vote please
representative bill nelson
representative pearl representative
perez
representative rice nope
representative
you're okay
representative testerman
representative walsh
representative tucker
you're all setting our representative
tucker registered thank you
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend with the state of
the vote
194 having voted in the affirmative 151
on the negative
house bill 153 is laid on the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 167 fn an act
relative to net energy metering limits
for customer generators and the purchase
of output of limited electrical energy
producers having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
nick white for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative kat
mcgee for the minority of the committee
for what reason does it memorize
mr speaker i'd like to move that house
bill 167 fn be laid upon the table
representative votes moves to lay house
bill 167 on the table are you
division votes been requested this will
be a division vote members please take
your seats
division
they're going wrong
that's right
they banned
all right the house had come to order
representative mcgee is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
yes thank you um if i know that new
hampshire's clean energy market ranks
dead last in the northeast
and if i know that artificially holding
back the free market by picking winners
and losers for net metered energy
results in higher transmission costs
so it's pennywise and pound foolish
and if i get that prolonged inaction
on support of local energy production
leads to the heaviest consumer costs
like the new hampshire utilities
predicted 40 percent increase
in 2022 fuel costs which we have
provided no strategies to avoid
then will i now press the green button
to pass a bill that would not transfer
costs to non-producers
but rather establish a sensible way
forward for the state of new hampshire's
clean energy markets to diversify our
energy portfolio
giving consumers choice
and limiting monopoly
representative mcgee
did you mean to say the green button
oh i'm sorry this is the lay on the
table yes it is
we definitely do not want to lay it on
the table so that's okay will you please
press the red button so that another
motion can be made thank you a true
parliamentary inquiry
no
that's what i mean it was
thank you
representative vos is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker
if i know that this bill duplicates
bills that were passed in the 2019-22
session
and that those bills were subsequently
vetoed by the governor and those vetoes
were sustained
would i now press the red button
the green button rather
to lay this bill on the table
again that's why we ask
the question is whether to lay house
bill 167 on the table
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
god
so
[Music]
real quick sir
representative rhodes
representative rice
representative lori sanborn
representative verville
representative walsh
representative johnson
representative gay
representative gallagher
have all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
representative johnson you're all set
representative pearl
just a reminder if you're in the room
you have to vote
it's registered thank you representative
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
185 having voted in the affirmative 153
in the negative house bill 167 is laid
on the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology energy to which was referred
as bill 172 an act establishing
greenhouse gas emis emission reduction
goals for the state and establishing a
climate action plan
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is an expedient to
legislate
representative tom lozada for the
majority of the committee
i'm sorry what
fluge i apologize
the minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report what the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative lee oxenham for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i move that house bill 172 be
laid upon the table representative vos
moves that house bill 172 be laid on the
table division this will be a division
vote members should probably still be in
their seats
division
[Music]
represent foes
representative mick williams is
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that new hampshire has
successfully passed our initial climate
plan targets
and if i know that we have exceeded the
25 by 25 target
and i if i further know that we have
accomplished this while significantly
growing new hampshire clean energy jobs
and substantially growing the new
hampshire economy
and
if i know that we have a window of
opportunity to make new hampshire a
clean energy innovation hub by
capitalizing on the coming boom in
offshore wind
what i vote read
to defeat the current motion so that a
better motion for the future of energy
jobs in new hampshire may be brought
forward thank you
representative is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that this
bill was incomplete as filed
because it talked about the benefits of
a climate action plan but it never
talked about the costs
what i now pla press the green button to
lay this bill upon the table
the question is whether to lay house
bill 172 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative bill boyd
representative judy
kennedy
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
180 having voted in the affirmative 159
and the negative house bill 172 was laid
on the table
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred house bill
308 an act relative to broadband access
to poll attachments having considered
the same report the same with the
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
jd bernardi for the committee
the question is on the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the committee report is adopted
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 376 an act
establishing a committee to study
applications of microgrids and
electricity supply
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
representative j.d bernardi for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass requisite representative peter
samsuch for the minority of the
committee
for what reason does the member rise
mr speaker i move that house bill
three
seven six
yeah i got that number right be laid
upon the table representative those
moves to a house bill 376 on the table
a division vote's been requested
members should take their seats
division
i don't think people went very far
the house would come to order
excuse me representative samsuch is
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
honorable members of the house if i know
that microgrids are a new vehicle for
new hampshire communities to build more
energy flexibility and resilience
and if i know that unh and some of the
other utilities have already been
experimenting with this concept
and that we should document their
experience both good and bad and that
that ex that experiment has now come to
an end
which needs to be solved
and if i further know that communities
considering the community power option
for their town
might want to consider building a local
microgrid as part of their
energy future energy designs
and if i also know that today is the
first anniversary of the january 6th
attack
would i now press
i also come to order would i now press
the red button to allow for further
discussion of this idea so we can
consider it thank
you representative vos is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the public public
utilities commission currently has a
docket open to study this issue and if i
further know that the university of new
hampshire's
experiment with
microgrids is ongoing and that our
committee
has
committed to sending a letter to the
university to get a report back
on the progress of that study
and that effort
would i now press the green button
to lay this bill upon the table
the question is whether to lay house
bill 376 on the table
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative ammon
representative conley
representative egan representative grota
representative harriet gathright thank
you
representative muse
representative true
representative turcotte
representative yakubovic
so
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
184 have been voted in the affirmative
152 and the negative house bill 376 is
laid on the table
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 382
an act establishing a commission to
study the utility rate structure of
demand charges having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
fred plett for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation at the bill ought to pass
representative lucius partial for the
minority of the committee
for what reason does remember us
mr speaker i move that hb 382 be laid
upon the table
representative vos moves that house bill
382 be laid on the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it house bill 382 was laid
on the table
thank
you majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 394
an act establishing a commission to
study the short and long-term impacts of
pending national and regional carbon
pricing mechanisms on new hampshire's
residents agriculture wildlife natural
resources based tourism sector and
commercial enterprises
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that has been expedient to
legislate representative douglas thomas
for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative lee oxenham
for the minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i move to lay house bill 394
upon the table representative votes
moves to lay house bill 394 on the table
division votes been requested members
please take your seats
division
who's got the pi
okay
um probably not 549.
the house will come to order
representative oxenham is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that regional and national
carbon pricing measures are currently
under consideration
and if i know that such regional and
national programs will have real world
impacts on the new hampshire economy
would i then support establishing a
study commission
to monitor these developments and ensure
that new hampshire is best positioned to
maximize our opportunities and minimize
any negative feedback
by pushing the green button thank you
did you mean to say green
thank you sir i did intend to say red
sorry i couldn't hear
red got it
representative vos is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i know
that it is premature to form a
commission to study
what will happen if some pending
national plan is developed even though
there is no consensus
emerging about what such a national plan
might look like
and if i know that our legislature is
awash in committees and commissions
but i now plus press the green button to
lay this bill upon the table
the question is on whether to lay house
bill 394 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative abrami
representative all chiller
representative avalani
representative baldassaro
representative de silvestro
representative o'hara
representative moran representative oxel
have all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
191 having voted in the affirmative 151
and the negative
house bill 394 is laid on the table
the committee on science technology and
energy to which was referred to house
bill 410 an act establishing a committee
to study the requirements of reporting
by utility companies of information
required for evaluation of certain
utility property
for purposes of rsa 72 having considered
the same report the same with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
representative troy murder for the
committee the amendment is 2216
house record 48 pages 93-94
the question is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on the committee
report of ought to pass with amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nick
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred house bill 543 an act
establishing a commission to study
nuclear power and nuclear reactor
technology in new hampshire
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representative j.d
bernardi for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
peter samson from the minority of the
committee
the member from durham representative
horrigan is recognized to speak against
the committee report thank you thank you
very much mr speaker
back in november i subbed on science and
technology and energy i'm using a
judiciary it was an interesting day good
change of pace
and we disposed of eight count of eight
commission and study committee bills
i've sponsored
some of those bills myself but it's hard
to get too worked up for over these
bills the end result these bills
typically a report which in rare cases
no one ever reads and it's pretty hard
to find them even if you do want to read
them
and um
there were six bills two of them were
not controversial we just passed one a
second ago another one was on regular
calendar this there were six more that
were controversial we just tabled five
of the first six
they were itl gym committee um
and the stats basically the reasoning
boiled down to is
um
nobody really cares about these issues
anymore there's no need for the
committee there's nothing more to be
found out about them
and
i
all the five the five that we just
tabled those are issues at least my
constituents are very worried about the
reliability the energy grid
climate change
can i ask the member to suspend for a
moment yes thank you that's getting
really really noisy in here if the
member has a right to be heard
sorry please continue and finally there
was broadband where i believe
maybe i'm misinterpreting believe we
said like we already know everything
there's about the topics there's no need
to study it anymore but certainly
i hear from mikey statements all the
time about each of those three topics
which brings us to the next one this one
which is about uh
nuclear energy and i hear a lot about
for my constituents too we don't want
any nukes we've been living in the
shadow of seabrook for
almost 50 years now
and you know we've had uh
we've had disasters in pennsylvania at
three mile island
in
ukraine and chernobyl and
most recently a few years ago in japan
and fukushima
we don't want that happening on the
seacoast of new hampshire and
there's a long laundry list of
technologies
most of which
it's fine somebody wants to study them
but i'm not sure what a
commission
new hampshire legislative commission
could add to it particularly with the
resources we usually
give those committees which is basically
nothing
so
also nuclear power technology it's not
safe
it's not renewable
and actually it isn't even carbon free
despite what was said in the blurb so
we don't want nukes here in new
hampshire and we certainly don't need
another commission as the
chair of the science and technology
energy pointed out
we are supposedly awash in committees
and commissions so this is definitely
is definitely
one more commission that we
at least the people of new hampshire
that i hear from do not want so please
please vote red on the otp so an
alternative motion can be introduced
thanks thank you
noise level's still pretty high
the member from portsmouth
representative samson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr thank you mr speaker
honorable members of the house
i ask you to overturn this committee
recommendation of h for hb 543
which calls for a commission to be
established to study nuclear power and
reactor technology in new hampshire
regardless of your personal feelings
regarding nuclear energy you should
consider that the goals of this
commission are very broad and very
technical and that most of the issues
referenced in this bill are not under
the jurisdiction of the state of new
hampshire but are in fact purview of the
federal government
i am personally i have personally been a
career physicist for approximately 45
years
including positions involving nuclear
energy radioactivity and atomic physics
during that time i had regularly
encountered numerous scientists and
listened to many talks on the very
subjects mentioned in this bill
and to be frank i would be very curious
about reviewing many of them again after
many years
however i would consider this more of a
science project that would be
complicated technically and very time
consuming and not something that would
have practical benefits for the state of
new hampshire
if such a bill were more focused on a
very few specific issues that had
relevance for new hampshire
it might be worth studying these issues
however however in its current form it
is a bill that's addressing too many of
these issues that the commission would
not be able to handle in a sensible time
span that is why i recommend that you
vote to overturn the otp recommendation
by pressing the red button
so that an it motion can be made thank
you very much mr speaker thank you
the member from londonderry
representative thomas is recognized to
speak in support of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
here's the speaker
this is not
our father's nuclear technology
we're in 2022
there is new new
nuclear technology out there
having recently returned from an ncsl
conference as a member of the energy
task force we received the briefing on
the new
new nuclear technology specifically
small scale nuclear module tech
technology
it's out there and it's it's uh usable
even the air force is buying one and
having installed up in alaska
we need to look at the new type of
technology that can really help our
state
even the eu has recently classified
nuclear
energy as green
nuclear energy will have zero emissions
now it may not be in the short term but
we need to start a conversation
on how we can adapt
if possible any type of this new nuclear
technology to help us produce zero
emissions in a much more efficient way
than we're doing now
the proposed commission
would work with the department of
nuclear regulatory commission department
of
of energy and many other agencies that
we have listed in this
commission
to uh to talk about the theoretical
viable options that that we can focus on
i urge the people the court here
to look and adopt this commission that
we can study this new technology and
possibly even eliminate some of the
nuclear waste that the current
technology is providing
the committee voted 15-6
to establish this committee i urge
the legislatures here to vote green on
this commission
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
d2 where
over here d2
what reason does it remember us uh will
the previous speaker uh receive a
question please
sorry he does not yield all right thank
you
question is on the majority committee
report of ought to pass are you ready
for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed name
[Applause]
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the majority of the committee on science
technology and energy which was referred
to house bill 549 an act relative to the
energy efficiency resource standard and
the system benefits charge
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
douglas thomas for the majority of the
committee
the committee amendment is 2205 in house
record 48
pages 97-98
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it
has been expedient to legislate
representative peter samsuch for the
minority of the committee
the question is on the majority
amendment
2205 h
the member from concord representative
mick williams is recognized to speak
against the amendment
thank you mr speaker
new hampshire's latest three-year energy
efficiency plan
would have produced significant cost
savings for all new hampshire ratepayers
in the hundreds of millions of dollars
why because energy efficiency is the
cheapest form of energy it's the energy
you don't have to buy because you don't
need to use it
the 2020 plan
would have increased funding for the new
hampshire saves program which is a
proven cost cutting program with roughly
150 million to 350 million dollars
returned to new hampshire citizens for
energy efficiency projects
this would have insulated town halls
installed money-saving heat pumps and
businesses and residences across the
state
allowed our own small business owners to
perform
energy efficiency
programs
and
increased our small businesses who do
energy efficiency work in this nascent
and growing
industry
this would have reduced electricity
bills across the board for all new
hampshire residents
not just for the owners of the buildings
who receive an energy efficiency audit
and insulation or blower door program
because the prices we pay for energy
reflect our combined total use
these prices go up with increased use
especially in the highest cost peak
periods
the authors of this amendment do not
recognize that energy efficiency
investments pay off year after year and
provide accelerating value over time the
focus is on the short term outlay when
we need to look at the overall long-term
results
if you switch out light bulbs that use
one-sixth of the energy
or
install appliances that are 250 percent
more energy efficient
or you add insulation that keeps heat
inside your building you cut your energy
use
and that cuts not only energy bills
but also the amount of energy needed
across the grid
energy efficiency cuts energy costs and
prices let's be clear this amendment
does one thing
it cuts energy efficiency funding
putting cost-effective upfront
investments out of reach for towns
businesses and families
the new hampshire saves programs are
subjected to a rigorous cost benefit
analysis which ensures that this program
provides benefits that exceed their cost
on average the return is a two to one
for new hampshire saves but frequently
it's three and four to one
it's estimated that under the 2020 plan
the system's benefit charge which funds
new hampshire saves would save new
hampshire electric customers
525 million dollars over the first three
years
and 1.3 billion with a b
dollars over 10 years we are currently
experiencing peak utility costs in the
winter in new hampshire all of our
constituents can benefit from reduced
utility costs
and yes this is called the system's
benefit charge because it benefits all
users across the entire system
passing this amendment would mean not
making these cost-saving investments
and that means you're being asked to
vote to increase ratepayer bills by
hundreds of millions of dollars
over 10 years by over a billion dollars
unnecessarily
at the expense of new hampshire's
businesses residents and economy
please fund new hampshire saves
invest that money in new hampshire and
don't waste it build a thriving new
hampshire economy built on local
businesses local jobs and yankee thrift
defeat this amendment
thank you
member from epping representative vos is
recognized to speak in support of the
majority amendment
thank you mr speaker the majority
amendment
sets the funding mechanism for energy
efficiency in our state the system
benefits charge
into statute
and it sets it at the highest level that
it's ever been in its history
in addition to that
it provides a mechanism
to increase the system benefits charge
year over year
by a stable and predictable amount
the
three-year average of the consumer price
index plus 0.25 percent
this will allow energy efficiency
programs to grow
in a stable and affordable manner
and provides predictability to those
programs going forward
but more importantly than that
the majority amendment will save
ratepayers money
it will keep increases in the system
benefits charge
in an affordable range of some five to
ten million dollars a year
now that contrasts sharply with the
energy efficiency plan that was proposed
to the public utilities commission about
a year ago that would have raised
ratepayer charges by 30 to 70 million
dollars year over year
so what that means to you and i as
average rate players
is the difference between a two to eight
dollar per month charge for energy
efficiency
as opposed to an 8 to 16
a month charge
but ultimately
the most important thing that the
majority amendment does
is it
puts the legislature back in control of
the funding mechanism for energy
efficiency
since this funding mechanism mechanism
is essentially a tax on electricity
only the legislature should have the
authority or has the authority the
constitutional authority to set that
rate
therefore i ask the members to
accept the committee amendment
it is the essence
of the bill
thank you mr speaker
thank you the question is on
majority committee amendment 2205
for what reason does the member rise i
need to call for a division vote mr
speaker thank you
this will be a division vote members
please take your seats
[Music]
who requested the roll call
representative edwards requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
roll paul
nice one
all right
house will come to order
representative mental is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know this amendment
cuts funding for cost-effective new
hampshire saves programs
from the projected levels of the 2020
triennial plan
and if i know
that losing these investment dollars
results in raising electricity prices
for ratepayers across the system
by hundreds of millions of dollars
and if i also know
that this amendment does nothing
to cut into the billions of new
hampshire energy dollars that are being
sent out of state annually or to cut our
fossil fuel use
would i then vote against this amendment
and push the red button
it's really loud in here again
representative vos is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that amendment 2205 sets the
system benefits charge at 2020 levels
which is the highest level it's ever
been in the history of the state
and also allows for that
system benefits charge to grow year over
year by a formula that is both
affordable and sustainable
and if i know
that amendment 2205
puts the legislature back in control
of essentially an attacks on electricity
would i now press the green button to
support the committee amendment
this is a division vote
sorry it's a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative ellis
represent marjorie smith
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
187 having voted in the affirmative 156
in the negative the amendment is adopted
bills on second reading and open a
further amendment
representative mann moves amendment
2299-h
which would have been distributed with
your paccus
representative samsung is recognized to
speak in favor of the floor amendment
thank you mr chair and mr speaker
while the minority is of the opinion
that hb 549
even with the majority amendment is
still seriously flawed
we offer amendment 2 2021
2299 as an important improvement
ideas for it have been borrowed from
suggestions made by one of our majority
committee colleagues
this amendment addresses two critical
issues
it addresses the request by the public
utilities commissioners
office of consumer advocate
to explicitly put into their legislation
the existence and role of the energy
efficiency resource standard the eers
and additionally it includes a badly
needed simplification of the rules
around the system's benefits charge
but it firmly opposes the notion of
setting low ceilings on that charge
which is the primary funding mechanism
for new hampshire states
this is the
this is the program that funds energy
efficiency and renewable energy and is
currently critically underfunded
often running out of funds by july first
of each year
therefore this amendment does not
include specific funding levels or a
specific mechanism for annually
increasing those funding levels
that is because we believe that funding
levels should be increased significantly
and also
because we have been assured by a senior
member of the other body that the final
version of hb 549 will undergo a
complete replacement at which time
needed fixes will be made
that is why this amendment is only a
small down payment on that improvement
we hope that will be made and which is
why i ask you to give it your support so
please press uh
please press the green button to uh
support amendment 22.99
thank you mr speaker and i request a
division vote
thank you the member from stratford
representative harrington is recognized
to speak against the four amendment
thank you mr speaker um
a couple of things i think we've got to
get straight here because we're dealing
with myths here rather than reality we
keep being told over and over again no
matter how much money you spend on
energy efficiency it's never enough if
you spend a million dollars people want
10 million if you spend 10 million they
want a hundred million the simple fact
is that just throwing money at energy
efficiency projects is not economically
efficient if you have to spend a
thousand dollars to save the megawatt
hour that you can buy for 50 dollars
that's not a good plan for anybody so
what backs this up all we have to do is
look to our friends to the south
massachusetts where they've spent
money many many times on ndg fishermen
see what we've had i believe it's in the
billions of dollars now and yet the last
time i checked the ever source rates for
eastern massachusetts this is the whole
total rate
was slightly higher than the eversource
rates in new hampshire if the if
throwing huge amounts of money in energy
efficiency was the solution to lower
electric rates theirs would be much
lower than ours not slightly higher
so what does this amendment do is was
just stated
the
approved amendment majority amendment
takes the authority for raising the
system benefit charge and puts it where
it belongs with the legislature it is in
fact a tax now the system benefit charge
is supposed to benefit the system but a
lot of the money has little and no
benefit to the system because when your
neighbor's house gets insulated his oil
bill goes down but his electric bill
hardly changes at all it doesn't have
any effect on the electric system one
way or the other
so they take this this amendment would
take that out and return it to
the
uh what i assume is be the program that
was rejected by the public utilities
commission as being not efficient and
way too costly
so they want to put this uh thing in the
energy efficiency resource standard into
law that's the standard that resulted
that was rejected by the puc because it
was just way way overpriced so
in closing just remember
throwing money at energy efficiency does
not necessarily save you money
massachusetts is proof of that
the system benefits charge is
effectively a tax and the setting of
that charge belongs in the legislature
thank you
before we move on
we've got a bipartisan problem here
both sides are making a lot of noise and
it's really hard to hear the speakers
there i'm actually at the point where
i'm trying to calculate the noise level
because i'm worried that if i stop
and say everyone should quiet down while
one's speaking will it look even-handed
it shouldn't be that way
we should care that they put work into
their speech
that
it's hard to go up there and speak in
front of hundreds of people and we
should respect the work that they put
into this and just be quiet and listen
to them i'm learning things listening to
them so
let's just give them the respect that
they deserve all of us please
the house will be in order
all right
representative samson should ask for a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take your seats
your vision
sure
all right
the question is on floor amendment
2299-h
representative mann is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that there is no
constitutional problem
with raising the system's benefit charge
in that the constitution
gives permission for agencies to
gives explicit permission for the public
utilities commission
or any other agency to raise the rates
and i also know
that the
purpose of energy these energy
efficiency projects are not just to save
money they also include reduction of co2
emissions which has effects that may
concern our children and our
grandchildren
if i further know that
our economy the new hampshire economy
dumps 85 to million 90 million dollars
per year to import heating oil
with the effects cascading down the
economy
and if i further know that a program of
competent energy efficiency work
on the willing
owners of homes and other buildings
would begin to stem this outflow of
money
and over the long run would produce an
accelerating and you have to do the math
to see this
an accelerating growth of savings that
outstrips the cost
and that the cost in any effect in any
event
is comparable to one or two or three
led bulbs
we're talking about
kilowatt hours saved by the led bulbs
beating
the system's benefit charge
and if you can't afford three bulbs i'll
show you how you can afford 20.
remember suspend for a sec this is
what's going on
yeah there you go
would i now press the green button to
pass
on the red button
to
defeat
the gree
the green button
to pass
house bill 549 with my amendment
2022-209 which is not what's on the
display
close enough so that we can get control
of our energy expense our co2 emissions
and so on thank you
all right the house has come to order
representative votes is recognized for
parliament representative harrington is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this amendment would try to
restore the flawed program that was
rejected by the public utilities
commission as being way too expensive
and i know it would remove the authority
for raising what is effectively a tax
the system benefit charge from the
legislature and give it to an agency
would i now push the red button and
defeat this amendment
the question is on floor amendment 2299h
this is a division vote
okay making sure i have it right
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative johnson
representative lebranch
representative lynn
representative massimilla
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
155 having voted in the affirmative 189
in the negative the amendment fails
and we are back to the majority
committee report of octopass
with the majority amendment the member
from hollis representative mcgee is
recognized to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker nice to see you
again
um house bill 549 is amended does
several things that the minority
disagrees with
it lowers investment for energy
efficiency at a time when the value of
those investments is rising along with
the rising fuel prices
it halts essential forward progress as
though the benefits of the new hampshire
saves program have not been proven
it calls for changes
to the easy board's involvement and role
in state energy planning and that's a
board that myself and my colleague from
eppong are both
appointed house
representatives to
and those of us who've been in the
legislature for a while know that
stakeholder boards are a great deal for
new hampshire
and they are how we get incredible work
done
out of talented people for no money
so in that way
the easy board is truly an extension of
our citizen legislature except that in
the case of the easy board the members
do often bring high levels of expertise
to bear on the problems that we ask them
to solve
so we think that the easy board should
have
that role in planning energy efficiency
they are not politicians by design
we see no reason uh to fix something
that was not broken
the minority also takes exception to the
redefining of rate setting as being the
role of the legislative or executive
branches of government
rather than the energy regulators who
were supposed to remain separated by a
bright red line when the new department
of energy was sold to us as part of the
budget trailer bill so the minority does
not agree with the thrust of the bill as
amended
however
hb 549 does provide a vehicle
to fix the drastic upheaval
of the public utility commission's
november decision
on the weatherization companies and
utilities who administer the new
hampshire saves program
although this bill does not leverage the
return on investment of energy
efficiency to the degree that we believe
the new hampshire saves program has
earned
passing hb 549 today although against
our instincts
will allow the legislative process to
proceed
toward fixing what was broken by that
puc order
it will help restore the faith of new
hampshire small businesses who are
counting on us to reinstate essential
new hampshire saves funding
we ask you to pass this far from
terrific bill
so that it has a chance to become a
rescue vehicle for all the uncertainty
imposed on the dedicated men and women
who weatherize our homes
and love their purposeful new
hampshire-based jobs because they know
and we know
their work has never been more needed
and i ask for division vote
thank you
the member for mapping representative
votes is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
as my distinguished colleague from
hollis just pointed out
house bill 549
will address a current problem
with our energy efficiency programs
the public utilities commission reset
the system benefits charge funding
mechanism back to 2019 levels as of
january 1st of 2022
by passing this bill
those levels would be reset back up to
the 2020 level which as i mentioned
earlier is the historic high for the
state of new hampshire
but more importantly
hb549
addresses
a significant problem
for the lowest income rate payers in new
hampshire
they suffer the most
when electricity prices go
sky high
that's because they pay proportionally
more
of their income for energy
so taxes like the system benefits charge
are regressive
by nature
and that makes it imperative that
increases to the system benefits charge
should be modest
and they should be predictable
and that's what
hb549 does to the system benefits charge
now we all know that energy efficiency
makes sense
everybody
should understand how it benefits their
personal and professional lives
and therefore some portion of sbc funds
should be used to raise public awareness
of the need for energy efficiency
and hp 549 does that
by
allocating to the
energy efficiency and sustainable engine
energy board the easy board
one percent
of sbc funds for the purpose of
promulgating information about the
benefits of energy efficiency
we have to remember
that people are somewhat reluctant to
spend money on energy efficiency because
the costs
are up front you have to pay them first
but the benefits accrue over time
and so you don't really
get what you pay for
the day you hand over the check
and that's one reason why people don't
rush out to do energy efficiency
projects
lastly i want to close here by saying
reminding people that if you look it up
in the dictionary a tax is defined as
quote
a sum of money demanded by a government
for its support or for specific
facilities or services
levied on incomes property sales etc
unquote
or
putting again
a burdensome charge obligation duty or
demand unquote
by this definition
the system benefits charge qualifies as
a tax
because it is demanded by government
and it's levied upon electricity sales
and i would remind you all
that the new hampshire constitution
authorizes only the general court
to impose taxes
thank you mr speaker
representative samson's request for roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members please take
your seats
roll call
the house will come to order
representative mental is recognized for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that funds raised through the
systems benefits charge pay for energy
efficiency programs to the very popular
new hampshire states and if i know that
all our surrounding new england states
are outperforming us in reducing energy
demand through energy efficiency
if i know that because we are falling
behind
new hampshire will continue to pay a
larger and larger part of our new
england's
energy transmission costs
but if i also know
that failing to pass this legislation
will
if i also know that
because of decisions at the puc
that failing to pass this legislation
will totally eviscerate the progress we
have made toward reducing our energy
demand
would i
hold my nose
and press the green button
and vote for this bill
simple
representative harrington
without holding my nose i'll just say
push the green button
the question is on the majority
committee report
house
house bill 549 ought to pass with
amendment
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative alicea
[Music]
all right
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attempt to the state of
the vote
all right and
and the house will come to order
343 or everybody
voting on the affirmative and no one
disagreeing
the committee reports adopted and i
think you all needed that moment
mr speaker
i'm at a1
can i ask the
remarks made on hb
put in permanent
journal
without objection
thank you
mr speaker
what reason does a member rise i have a
point of order i have a question for the
speaker
what is your point of order
mr speaker i need your help
i have been here for 25 years
and something happened today that i have
never seen before and i need you to
explain it to me
a standing committee the judiciary
committee
had a majority
vote
on a bill with an amendment
and that was sent to the clerk's office
many months ago in i believe it was
still october when it was sent
and i know
that the clerk and the speaker are very
careful to make sure
that the
calendar
is accurate and appropriate and follows
our rules
today
about three minutes before a bill was
called
i was
told by the clerk
that you had ruled
that a majority amendment not a floor
amendment a majority amendment that has
been in the calendar for ages
was ruled non-germane
and i don't think i have ever seen that
happen
i know i was not told about three until
three minutes before
i asked the clerk who was so courteous
in telling me if in fact the chair of
the committee knew about that and he
said he did not think so but he would go
and tell the chair
and
i was
flummoxed flabbergasted i don't know
what word to use but the result of this
of your decision
is that
there are women in this state
who are going to have to go through a
non-medical procedure representative
that's not a point of order you're now
you're trying to get into making a
speech then i will stop at this point
and ask you just in a very respectful
way
procedurally
explain to me how something like this
could happen in good faith thank you i
will i will attempt to do that
representative thank you i had
200 bills
that were retained
and
unfortunately i did not get to that bill
right away when it was sent over
when i was looking at it maybe about a
week and a half ago
and i took a close look at it
and i took a close look at the original
bill
that's when i determined that
if it came up which it did not
if that came up then i was
inclined to say that it was not going to
be germaine to the subject matter of the
original bill
i thank you for your explanation but i
hope you understand
that i can't quite get my mind around it
as following the normal careful
procedure that you and the clerk use
and i am
distressed about it and i wanted to make
that point in the most respectful way
possible
and i thank you for doing that
representative thank you
the clerk has an announcement thank you
mr speaker uh 15 to 20 of you were
staying overnight tonight at the hotel
we've worked with the hotel to provide
some flexibility on their cancellation
policy to accommodate our situation of
ending early for those of you who have a
single night reservation for tonight and
need to cancel as long as you have not
checked into your room yet you can
cancel your reservation without any
penalty for those of you who stayed last
night and would be cutting your
reservation short by canceling tonight
you should also be able to cancel your
stay for tonight with no penalty
[Applause]
what reason the member rise mr speaker
i'd ask that to call a queen between the
member from mad berry and the speaker
that just commenced be placed in the
permanent journal
what
i was going to say without objection but
i hear objections
so we need to vote on it
all those in fit
the division has been requested
so this will be on placing
in the permanent journal
the discussion that just
roll call has been
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded
rocole
what is before us is placing
the
recent the discussion that would just
took place in the permanent journal this
is going to be a roll call vote
the house
the chair recognizes representative
shirtless for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know
that i appreciate
the colloquy that took place between the
member from madbury and yourself and the
answer uh that you extended to her
but mr speaker if i also know this is
somewhat unique in the new hampshire
floor
of the new hampshire house and it's the
first time i've seen this in my 18 years
that
a bill would be
ruled non-germaine so close to the
hearing on the floor
would i now push the green button to
have these remarks permanently placed in
the journal for future legislators to be
able to look at thank you mr speaker
the most
the motion before us is to place the
remarks in the permanent journal this is
a roll call vote
if you're in favor of placing the
remarks you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative belanger
representative mackey
representative pearl
representative walsh
representative tarosian
of all members voted that were present
house will attend this state of the vote
178 voting ray 158 voting a remarks will
be printed
we have seven bills left
four of those are off consent
so let's see if we can
move quickly and get out of here
committee on ways and means to which was
referred house bill 355 an act relative
to keno having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator timothy lang for the committee
amendment 2152h printed in house record
48 page 91.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it an amendment is adopted
the question before us now is
the auto pass with amendment on house
bill 355
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the committee report is adopted
committee on ways and means to which was
referred house bill 364 an act expanding
the definition of charitable
organization to include fraternal
organizations for the purpose of holding
raffles having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment recommendation the bill ought
to pass with amendment senator jordan
early for the committee the amendment is
two one two three age printed in house
record 48 page 92
i are you ready for the question on the
amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question now is on house bill 364 as
autopass as amended are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred house bill
614 fn index exempting the state in
political subdivisions for payment of
the cost of compliance with the
renewable portfolio standard
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill locker pass
with amendment senator patrick obama for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator richard
ames for the minority of the committee
the amendment is 2238
h printed in house record 48 pages 106
107.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor adopting an
amendment say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the amendment is
adopted
the chair recognizes representative ames
to speak against the committee report
thank you
so i'm here to speak in opposition to
house bill 614
614 as amended
this is a poorly and illogically
constructed legislative proposal
as amended
the bill seeks to exempt
all new hampshire state and local
government
electricity consumption from continued
payment of a fairly allocated use-based
share
of the costs of new hampshire's
electricity renewable portfolio standard
this means that these new hampshire
government electricity users
unlike all
non-government users
would no longer pay a very small fee
currently set at .0053
cents per kilowatt hour
as the price of their continued
participation
in the state's renewable portfolio
standard program
as an in it unavoidable
consequence
of this categorical exemption
the fee for all non-governmental
electricity users
will increase
because paradoxically and unsustainably
the bill also provides that the
non-paying government users
will retain eligibility
to receive funds
and other benefits
from the
renewable portfolio systems
renewable energy fund
government users
will thus become classic
free riders
reaping the benefits of the renewable
portfolio standard program while freed
from sharing in its costs
the renewable portfolio standards
renewable energy fund
will also lose capacity
to make a difference
because energy provider alternative
compliance payments
the sole source of funding for the
renewable energy fund
will in inevitably inevitably
be reduced by the fallout from this bill
universal assessment on
and payment by all users
of a small renewable portfolio standard
consumption-based fee
is at the very heart
of this successful 14 year old program
that has been helping drive new
hampshire
towards the renewable and locally
produced
energy foundation on which new
hampshire's foundation
must be built
renewable portfolio standard
governmental free riders will undermine
and diminish the capacity of the
renewable portfolio standard to do its
job
assertions by house bill 1614
proponents that consumers
have been paying twice for the rps
once in their personal capacity and
again as taxpayers
are invalid individuals and businesses
pay the rps fund
fee
pay the rps fee
only on their own
home or business consumption of kilowatt
hours of electricity
while the fees on municipal
cap school county and state government
electricity use
are levied on entirely different
kilowatt hours of electricity use
despite claims by its sponsors
no meaningful evidence has been produced
supporting substantial
trump net substantial net property or
other tax savings resulting from this
bill
on the contrary
utility testimony
indicates that utility administrative
costs
would go up because of this bill
new rate classes would need to be
created and rate payers likely would
would for those reasons alone
end up with higher electricity bills
so i urge you
to vote no on the pending ought to pass
motion and i request a division
vote it's getting awful noisy in here we
only got a few bills left
chair recognizes representative abrami
thank you mr speaker
i'm going to face the audience it'll be
a little maybe they'll pay attention
thank you speaker
i rise to support
the otpa motion on house bill 614.
the policy portion of this bill was
reviewed by science and tech
our job was not to redo that our job was
twofold
our job and by the way this bill passed
over with a good vote on february 24th
from
the original policy committee and it was
referred to us in ways and means
what we did was we retained the bill
partly because
to understand the rps we required a
tutorial
in how that all worked
in which science detect was very helpful
in doing that for us
but mr speaker our role in ways and
means
was really twofold
one is to answer the question does this
bill have the potential of lowering
property taxes on municipalities
and all other political subdivisions of
the state political subdivisions
our towns their school districts
their
counties etc
and does it have the potential of
reducing demand for tax revenue from
state revenue generating sources that
was the first thing we had to look at
the second was
was will this bill have a detrimental
impact on the on the renewable energy
fund
which is a dedicated fund primarily
rep replenished by all alternative
compliance payments paid by the utility
companies
if there are not enough renewable energy
certificates
being sold
for by the renewable energy producers
now it took me a while to even figure
out what those words meant
and i don't expect everybody to
understand
how this all works but
the underlying bill which is the current
house position
does three major things it exempts the
state
and its political subdivisions from
paying the portion of the the electric
rates that pertain to the cost of a
compliance with the renewable portfolio
standard fine
it also it states uh that providers
which are the distributors of
electricity shall not be subject to
compliance for electric sales that have
been exempted this reduces the number of
renewable energy certificates
that the electric utilities have to buy
and thirdly it states that a political
subdivision of the state
but not the state may by majority vote
of the governing body
elect to continue payment of the amounts
as identified as cost of compliance with
the rps
simply stated
these subdivisions can opt out
of this program of of the exemption
mr speaker
so so that's
basically the policy that
we didn't change that was the policy
committee
what we was passed by this body so it's
kind of the house position
mr speaker the majority of ways and
means committee concluded the following
with estimates of electric cost savings
to the state in the range of 400 to 500
000 annually and clear savings to
political subdivisions
one example being epping
that estimated it would reduce electric
cost of three thousand dollars
potentially leading to less pressure to
raise state taxes
and local property taxes this bill was
has was was seen as a win for all
taxpayers of new hampshire by the
committee majority
second
in assessing the
the the fund the renewable energy fund
so
the impact on the renewal g fund is very
difficult to calculate
although even the puc says in the fiscal
note
that there may be a decrease in these
funds
but what
what they were really signaling is that
they may or may not be an impact the
majority of ways and means committee
interpreted this as a possible but not a
definite reduction
in
in the alternative compliance payments
which once again are the primary feeder
of the fund
in the fund the amount of acps that must
be paid by the utility distribution
companies are driven by
many underlying factors it's a
multivariate problem
it's very complicated first the weather
hot or cold rainy or dry windy not windy
things that impact generation of
renewable energy
the more renewable energy produced the
more reusable energy certificates
that can be sold
each year and that differs year to year
second the overall amount of electricity
sold which also varies by things like
the weather a hot summer means more air
conditioning use for instance the amount
of energy sold dictates the number of
reusable energy certificates that must
be bought which also varies here to the
air
our rps program has a regional market
of six new hampshire new england states
and new york
and what's the new renewable energy
certificates are bought and sold the
impact of this bill on such a large
market of which new hampshire is such a
small part will be extremely minimal
to a point where the impact of the acp
payments will hardly be felt again
alternate compliance payments are paid
by utility when
when there aren't enough recs on the
market to be bought
evidence of the complexity of the uh on
the variables of
that impact acp's
department revenue source for the fund
is the last five years of acp payments
so if you look at fiscal years 2017 to
those icp maintenance in 2017 were 2.7
million then it went to 4.8 million and
3.4 million and 3.9 million then 2.2
million so a range of anywhere from 2.2
million to 4.8 million over the last
five years
as you can see mr speaker
this whole acp thing and what what funds
the the fund
is very variable
year to year
and with that mr speaker i will just say
that
the ways it means concluded that
there's no we feel that there there will
be a negligible uh
impact on the removal of any fund
that uh that will result from this bill
and i i think i will leave it at that mr
speaker
there were few amendments but nothing
that was material to the bill
uh the original bill
and with that i hope everybody votes uh
yes on the lgpa motion thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker
a1
yes will the representative take a
question
the
representative does not take a question
thank you
the question before us is the majority
report about to pass as amended on house
bill 614
are you ready for the question
okay i didn't hear the division a
division has been called members will
take their seats
the vision
so
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative mcgee for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that house bill 614 proposes
that state and town subdivisions reclaim
pennies in energy
clean energy compliance payments in
exchange for losing the ability to save
thousands on their energy bills forever
and if i know that no one testified in
favor of this bill or these dramatic
cuts to our energy project funding
especially after they learned that as
amended hp 614 would make
utilities exempt from paying
the into the renewable energy fund that
pays back those dividends on our energy
bills
and if i know that the whole point of
compliance payments is that they're
designed to return more benefits to new
hampshire energy customers than they
cost
just like our energy efficiency programs
that were recently
decimated
at the request of no one
there will be a reduction in new
hampshire's ability to offer grants and
this will hurt our ability to move
forward in this in this realm
then would i be sure to push the red
button to show that those who elected us
uh
see that we understand that wrecking a
good policy is just as bad as passing a
bad one
thank you
chair recognizes the representative
major for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill as amended requires
that the state political subdivisions be
exempted from paying the portion of the
electric rates that cover the cost of
compliance with the renewable portfolio
standards
and that electric suppliers are required
to contract
fall rates that exclude cost of
compliance with the
renewable portfolio standards
and if i know that any political devel
subdivision
by majority vote of its governing body
may elect to opt in
to continue payment of the amount
identified as cost of compliance
with the renewable
portfolio standards
and if i further know that the policy
portion of this bill
was passed by the full house in february
and referred to the ways and means
committee
and finally
mr speaker
the majority of the ways and maine's
committee concluded that no approachable
negative impact the renewable energy
fund would result from this bill
then will you join me in the majority of
the committee and vote green to pass
this bill thank you
question is on the majority ought to
pass as amendment on house bill 614.
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations were open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative belanger
representative d lorenzo
representative herbert
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
177 voting 858 voting a committee report
is adopted
foreign
committee on criminal
we are on bills removed from the consent
calendar
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
408 an act relative to employment
restrictions for registered sex
offenders been considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator john bordenate for the committee
the amendment is 2177h printed in house
record 48 pages
92-93
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
committee amendment the eye's heaven and
committee amendment is adopted
the bill's on second reading opened a
further amendment
representative lynn is offering floor
amendment 2294h
printed in house record 52 page 7.
thank you mr speaker
i know it's late and we're all tired and
i appreciate your indulging me i will
try to be quick but i think i need to
give some explanation for why i ask that
this be taken off the consent challenge
currently rsa 632 a10
prohibits convicted sex offenders from
from obtaining employment or providing
volunteer service in specific kinds of
fields directed to providing services to
children that is working as a teacher a
day care worker a coach a boy or girl
scout leader and there's also some
language in it that arguably could be
could be applied more broadly
in 2019 the supreme court decided a case
called state versus proctor
which involved a convicted sex offender
who opened his who after release from
from his sentence opened his own
landscaping business and hired a minor
to work with him
he was charged with violating this
statute
his counsel made two arguments the first
was that the statute only applies to a
person who works as an employee or a
volunteer but not to a sex offender who
offers employment or volunteer service
as an employer and secondly that
landscaping was not the kind of work
that fell within the statute because it
was unlike teaching coaching boy scout
leader etc
the court unanimously agreed
with the with the defendant on the
second issue and reversed his conviction
but said that the legislature could
change the law if it wanted to
the amendment that was just adopted uh
by the prior vote
it does just that
and it does so by prohibiting a sex
offender from and now i'm quite it
removes all the specific language about
teacher and boy scout leader etc
and it replaces with is it replaces it
with this language quote from a
sex offender is prohibited from
providing any employment or volunteer
activity that provides direct services
to minors or supervision or oversight of
minors close quote
my problem with this amendment is that
it goes too far
under this amendment
a convicted sex offender
would not be able to get a job as a
checkout person at market basket or
cumberland farms or as a waiter at a
restaurant because in each of these
settings the sex offender might have
occasion to provide direct services to a
minor
virtually all sex offenders will
eventually really be really uh released
from jail the question we have to decide
is whether we want to make the
prohibition so restrictive that we
effectively prohibit sex offenders from
getting any kinds of jobs that may
reasonably be available to them they're
not likely to be
you know interviewed for the next uh
chairmanship of b of uh bae systems
these are the kind of jobs that market
basket incumbent farms and other places
like that that are likely to be to be
only ones available to them
if we do want to make the restriction
if we do want to make the law that
restrictive and we effectively guaran we
effectively guarantee that they will
spend their life on welfare and you and
i and our constituents will end up
paying for it
the the proposed amendment that i have
offered
avoids this problem by narrowing the
statute so that it retains the listing
of the specific types of prohibited
employment or volunteer service in the
current law but also adds language
prohibiting employment or volunteer
service that quote
requires the person to have regular
contact with or supervision of a minor
when other persons are not present
this and that quote close quote this
would not prohibit working as a grocery
or convenience store or at a restaurant
because normally such work occurs in a
public setting where other people are
around and therefore the sex offender
has little or no opportunity to take
advantage of a minor
the language of my proposed amendment
also is worded so that it covers both
the sex offender who is seeking
employment and one who offers an
employment
as an employer
i urge you
to approve to vote uh
ought to pass on this uh proposed
amendment and then i would and then if
if you do i would also hope you will
vote to approve the the bill as amended
thank you very much mr speaker
chair recognized representative verville
thank you mr speaker
the bill
was filed and had a committee hearing
and there certainly were issues
identified
with the original bill
that it was too broad in scope and a
subcommittee was formed and worked very
very diligently to come up with the
language that we have
i do not agree with the representative
that just spoke the language that we
passed earlier uh well i'm sorry that
that is the amendment
from the original bill
is for direct supervision
or close proximity working with
miners
so
i don't agree with the previous speaker
this bill will allow you to have some of
those jobs
but you can't be
supervising or in direct
you know
management
over minors
this bill
as it appears on the consent calendar
came out of the the committee i believe
it was 19 to 1. it was a bipartisan
amendment we had another issue
also unfortunately out of deerfield
with carnival ride operators that are
registered as sex lenders working
unsupervised with children all day long
and the original intent of a law was to
not allow that to happen
and the courts found the flaw in the
language and we worked very diligently
to close that loophole
this bill does not only protect
miners
but this bill also protects registered
sex offenders because that particular
crime has a very high recidivism rate
and by
disallowing
registered sex offenders into an
environment where they are more likely
to reoffend protects the registered sex
offender as well as the minor children
of new hampshire
i would request
that this body not adopt this amendment
and that we pass the amendment and the
bill as found on the consent
calendar
there was a lot of discussion in the
subcommittee about how limiting
this particular bill would be to
registered sex offenders and that's why
so much time was spent on the language
to
ensure that it wasn't so limiting in
scope that registered sex offenders
could not find work to support
themselves and their families but also
protect minors
and i believe that this amendment
is a step backwards
and that we're going to have to come
back at it again
and the trigger for coming back at it
again is going to be in a minor that has
been abused and there we have served no
one
to say that
they can't they can work with minors as
long as they're not alone
you can't guarantee that things happen
emergencies pop up and somebody has to
leave quickly and now we have the
potential of that registered sex
offender working in close proximity with
minors unsupervised you can't guarantee
it
i begged this body to please reject this
amendment and let us pass the bipartisan
amendment that came out of the
subcommittee and out of the committee
with a nineteen to one vote
thank you
the question before us is the adoption
bigger
will the remember we yield to a question
will remember yield to a question
yes remember yields you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you for
taking my question
um
i read this it says
that the prohibition of
direct anything that has direct
supervision or oversight of minors
can you explain to me
or what's the difference how that
doesn't preclude
the types of things
that the
lynn amendment addresses
because it seems to me that this would
record anybody from say working in a
grocery store or working at mcdonald's
so i thank the member for the question
and all i can tell you is what the
experts told me
so we had people
from judiciary we had people from
criminal justice and we had advocates
that work with registered sex offenders
and we all worked on this language
together we all agreed on this language
there was no party from any side of this
issue
that didn't sign off on the language
that's in the consent calendar
there is no need for further amendment
from what the committee done we trust
our committees to to to do the work to
do the right work i believe they did
that and so i'd ask you to reject the uh
the amendment thank you
the question before us is the lin floor
amendment two 2294h
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
division has been requested
i didn't
put the hammer down quick enough i guess
the division has been requested members
take their seats mr speaker
parliamentary inquiry
state your inquiry mr speaker we called
the vote
and the gavel came down i
i did not call the vote in in time for
the person to yell division thank you if
i could do a pi it'd be obliged
this will be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
robert for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that the committee
spent
hours working on this bill
and if i know
that all interested parties in these
matters
were present and participated openly
in those committee hearings and that the
language of the bill and the amendment
contained in the consent calendar was
agreed on by all parties
and that this is a good bill
that will protect minor children of new
hampshire
and will also protect registered sex
offenders from the chance of recidivism
without precluding them of employment
opportunities as has been suggested by
others
would i now not press the red button so
that we could return to the original
bill
and the committee amendment
that was 19 to 1. thank you mr speaker
the question before us is
the
wind floor amendment two two nine four h
this is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative allegro
representative alicia lekkis
got it now thank you
representative page
representative notter
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
73 voting yay 263 voting nay
the lynn floor amendment fails
we're back
d2
yes
um i have a motion
state your motion
i would like to re-refer this uh hb 408
back to criminal justice so that they
can
address the concerns
with with uh representative lynn
and we can hear this again thank you
technically we can do it but because the
reporting deadline has already passed in
this bill
and we're in the 2022 section you would
have to have a two-thirds majority to do
that
do you still wish to move forward
thank you all withdraw the motion thank
you thank you
we're now back to
house bill 408 ought to pass as amended
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
the committee on criminal justice and
public safety to which was referred
house bill 526
act relative to the fine for the sale or
possession of cannabis having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution
that it is supposed to be it was printed
wrong referred to interim study uh chair
recognizes representative abbas
thank you mr speaker
a little bit of confusion that we had on
the criminal justice public safety
committee
apparently the calendar the journal says
that it was in itl
and actually it was a it was supposed to
be referred for interim study
and therefore it was taken off the
consent calendar i believe by a member
but we would ask that be in hb526 be in
term study
thank you
it was reported incorrectly
the question before us
is the committee report on house bill
to be referred to interim study
not an expedient to legislate
you are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
your eyes have it the committee report
is adopted as interim study
the committee on election law to which
was referred house bill 362 an act
relative to domicile of students for
voting purposes having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate
representative james clearly for the
committee
mr speaker mr speaker
does a member rise i have a motion i
move to table house bill 362.
motion is in order
motion before us is the table house bill
362.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
division
a division has been requested the chair
is unsure
this will be a division vote members
take your seats
this this will the question is on the
tabling motion on house bill 362. this
will be a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button loading stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
house will come to order please
representative post you're all set
representative kretion
representative o'brien
representative page
representative thomas
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
312 voting a 25 voting nay
house bill 362 was laid on the table
this is it the last one
committee on transportation to which was
referred house bill 116
an act relative to personal delivery
devices and mobile carriers having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation
the bill ought to pass with amendment
senate stephen smith for the committee
amendment two one nine night h printed
in record 48 pages 78 79
are you ready for
the question on the amendment all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted
the chair recognizes representative
guthrie to speak against the committee
report
thank you mr moderator i'm sorry mr
speaker it's always good to be the last
vote i'm glad that you can all see me
this is it and i'll be as brief as i can
mr speaker
although i wish i could be on a more
positive note so i'll just read my notes
mr speaker
house bill 116 is a bill that specifies
much needed regulations and limits for
the use of personal delivery devices and
mobile carriers you can all see them on
the internet if you want to look at the
internet you'll see what we're talking
about
and what these vehicles look like
i ask that this bill be removed from the
consent calendar because when i read the
bill
in the article i was concerned that in
some cases
it seemed to me to be an accommodation
for what is being set forward by the
delivery industry
mr speaker this
bill allows vehicles that weigh up to 80
pounds plus their cargo
to travel at speeds up to 10
to 12 and a half miles up on sidewalks
roadways crosswalks
we need to be more concerned with the
safety
on our roads and our
pedestrians than this
as a selectmen i also was concerned with
the lack of local control
this
bill states in part a local authority
may not ban these delivery
mr speaker
i think we will be better served to vote
no on ought to pass
and send this bill to interim study
the chair recognizes representative
stephen smith speak in favor of the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
the reason it's important to pass this
bill is because in the absence of it
there are no regulations matter of fact
they're being tested on the roads and
sidewalks right now we had one rolling
around out in front of the state house
who contributed to this bill the
manufacturers the industry the operators
and the department of safety
so we don't need to study it more we did
that this summer
and got all that input together the
weights and speeds that you find in the
bill are what they use
we'll establish those parameters most
importantly we establish liability
levels and require them to carry
insurance right now
they can run around the streets of
manchester without that
so it's there's generally a
misconception that without these
regulatory packages
they can't go well they can they are and
it's important for us to get ahead of it
so please support the unanimous
transportation committee report of
octopath as amended
the question before us
is the ought to pass as amended motion
on house bill 116.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Music]
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
i'm asking everybody to stay seated for
just a few more minutes
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne for third
reading motion
uh resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early recession that the
business of the late session be in order
at the present time that the reading of
bills be by title only in resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
to third reading be read a third time at
this resolution and that all titles and
bills be the same as adopted and when
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today it be to
meet at the call of the chair
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay he hides it the motion
is adopted
the clerk has an announcement thank you
mr speaker please a reminder please
deposit your clickers at the various
tables as you're leaving again please
wait as we do have a few more unanimous
consents and announcements um
for those members that we had to replace
your clickers and your name is not on
the back please bring them forward to me
when we've concluded thank you
first of all
i think you all deserve
a big round of applause for all that
we've done in the past two days
we
when we were setting this up we were
unsure if we could get through all this
in two days and
we've done it we've got through it in
two days
first of all i want to try and thank the
doubletree hotel staff
the auto and video people
i want to really thank the law
enforcement who has made sure that we've
been kept safe even though there was no
danger
but most important
our general court staff
they have been amazing
the house will to attend will attend to
request for unanimous consent
the
chair recognizes representative disarro
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i come here today
as a veteran a loyal dedicated american
a citizen
somebody who served my country for over
22 years
i have many in this room on both sides
of the room
that served in the military whether you
serve four years or you serve six years
or twenty thirty years like myself
i've got friends that served one term
two terms five terms twenty ten terms up
the fifteen terms that i know that
served in afghanistan
mr speaker
i have been heartbroken
since august 26th
mr speaker
fellow marines
that were called into duty
over in kabul
it was a sad day for us veterans many
you here in the left and the right side
here have relatives that served in the
military
many just like myself were i sat in the
barracks after the saigon evacuation and
watch what happened on how we left
americans behind
should it never happen
i sat at home and the calls i got from
fellow veterans
that were so disgusted on january 26th
we gave up our ground around the
airfield
that was one of the most fortified
airfields in the world
we moved over to kabul
we lost veterans that we should have
never lost
seven object your ass okay all right
okay i apologize i'm sorry i apologize i
should have never ever said that but
it's in my heart
the house will be in order
let's not end on a nasty note please
consent
consent has been withdrawn
shall the member continue
it's a it's a vote
are you ready for the question
[Music]
a division has been requested
members take their seats
[Music]
a roll call has been requested
you've already put the question offers
are taking their seats
as i've been i've been informed remember
i've already put the question members
have taken their seats
besides everybody's already standing up
so i wouldn't know who was standing and
who wasn't
this is a division vote
if you're in favor of
remembering continue to speak and
uninana has been consent
you will vote
yay you will vote you press the green
button if you are opposed you will post
it
you will press the red button
hold on 14 stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
uh there are many members that have left
so i'm going to just read through this
if you've
if you're here vote if not
don't know what to say
representative adjudance almy
baruti bartlett bullier belanger
uras ordnay connors kretion chase cali
pitts bunker bradley
d lorenzo di silvestro
eagan goalie gorg green
herbert harley
mcaleer mick williams
ray newman
nutteruppum
oxnam
piedra peterson
rung
schamberg
suzanne smith timothy smith
toll wall
wolf westin was here
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
[Applause]
membership 213 voting yay 77 voting a
the member may continue thank you mr
speaker mr speaker first of all i was
wrong for using that language here and i
i apologize for that but i'm not wrong
for what i'm saying here okay because i
lost brothers and sisters many years out
there lost brothers and sisters cousins
or whatever we lost
i was there in the barracks like i was
saying when during that vatican after
it was disgusting what went on where we
left americans behind
to see the same thing go on in our
country is tough for many we have
veterans committing suicide that
that served in all those tours that
protected american beliefs
that should have never happened i don't
blame just the president so don't take
this wrong i blame them generals i blame
the secretary of defense i blame all of
them the state department because their
failure to remember to bring home every
american all my years of training was to
remember as a marine not to leave one
veteran behind
and that's what happened
[Applause]
so i have fellow veterans that i know
around the country that are fighting and
i'm asking each and every one in this
room call these veterans up that are
depressed over what went on like the
vietnam veterans we don't want to do a
new generation of homeless veterans
because of what happened over there on
walking away we must make damn well sure
we don't relive what's going on with
saigon lessons learned so take care and
call and check on your veterans there's
no republican democrat in this these are
americans that fought for each and every
20 years in this world
mr speaker
i asked to memorialize in a moment of
silence when i am done
on these veterans
that were killed
in kabul
marine corps lands corporal david
espinoza
of rio gravel texas
marine corps sergeant nicole g
23 of roseville california
marine corps staff sergeant
darren taylor hoover 31 of utah
army staff side ryan ross
23 of courtroom he's 23
in corinton tennessee
marine corps corporal hunter lopez 22 in
india california
marine corps landscope o'reilly mccullum
jackson wyoming
marine lance corporal dylan
marola 20 of rancho cucamonga california
marine corps lance corporal kareem
nicole
20 of norco california
marine corps corporal david william
tyler page 23 of omaha
marine corps sergeant johnny rosary 25
lawrence massachusetts
marine corps corporal humberto sanchez
logansport india
marine corps lance corporal jared
schmidt 20
wentzville
montana
and naval hospital corpsman max soviet
22 of berlin heights ohio i asked for a
moment of silence
thank you mr speaker
may we all remember
those that served
and died protecting us and allowing us
to do what we do now mr speaker
c3
yes i move that the remarks of the
previous speaker be entered into the
permanent journal
without objection
mr speaker
uh diane schuett at b2
i would just point out to the body that
by the numbers it's obvious that
consent for the previous speaker to
continue was bipartisan and i would hope
that that spirit will continue for
ensuing speakers thank you
chair recognizes senator rogers for
unanimous consent
thank you mr speaker
one year ago today
we met in our kickoff house session in a
parking lot in durham
january 6 2021
began as a mr speaker i objected to
adversity
we gathered with a sense of hope
remember the member will
will cease there has been an objection
we will have another vote
this will be a division vote mr speaker
speaker roll call roll call
i've already claimed as i did on the
last objection that this will be a
division vote and i've already stated
that and i didn't take a roll call last
time i'm not taking it this time this is
going to be a division vote
division
this will be a division vote
if you're in favor of the membering
member continuing you will press the
green button if you are opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Applause]
same thing uh
representatives abbots
adjudance
bunker burrows cali pits cahill chase
christian
uh goalie
guthrie highland hunt
harrington
the flam close
kit ridge
ray and sue newman mcgee
nordgren mick williams not a rebel
piedra
porter
post to burge vinson
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will tend to stay to the vote
119 voting yay 114 140 voting
[Music]
remember
does not have the votes to continue
the chair recognizes representative
schultz under unanimous consent
thank you mr chair i feel a little
awkward after that
i'm uh disappointed that folks weren't
willing
at least a number of folks
to listen to
my in my state rep
um so it's very awkward to transition
from that to what i was gonna say but i
am also inspired even though i disagreed
with viewpoints as the daughter of a
marine
the size of the representative's heart
from londonderry
and the reading of the names of those
who perished i just want to thank him
for that
so i just made my transition even more
awkward but
what i wanted to talk about briefly
and i've heard mention of catholics
multiple times from our colleagues
across the aisle for what it's worth i'm
a devout catholic so i'm going to throw
a hail mary
um
we did not get to vote on the minimum
wage bill
and you know i didn't expect to win
necessarily but i want to extend an
olive branch
the economic crisis that new hampshire
is facing
the wage crisis the employee crisis
we have to acknowledge the fact
even if we wouldn't go about it the same
way
that all of our neighbors
vermont
maine and massachusetts on january 1st
all over the national news
raise their minimum wage
massachusetts is now double
what new hampshire defaults to with 7.25
most of our population
is on the border of new hampshire with
these states
our employers do not have a level
playing ground
the free markets in new hampshire
suffers because of that
i would also like to point out
that because a hundred and over
a hundred and forty four thousand
working granite staters
earn less
than fifteen dollars
an hour in this state
and we're the wealthiest state to
default
to 7.25
that it means
we as taxpayers
are paying
for the
public assistance that those full-time
workers
go on
as free market capitalists why would we
subsidize
the wages that those employers should be
paying
because if just a few dollars an hour
they would not need public assistance
some of us care about our tax
bills
i would suggest
and i've heard the phrase taxation is
theft
what should happen in a capitalist
society representatives employers the
representatives
the representative will
has
been consent has been withdrawn
so we need to have a vote
we'll have a division vote on whether
representative schultz
can continue
this is going to be
a division vote
if you're in favor of representative
schultz continuing you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button
floating stations are open for 30
seconds
we're right there
if all members had enough president had
an opportunity to vote
i also attended the state of the vote
75 voting yeah 127 voting a
the member cannot continue
representative osborne moves at the
house stand and resets for the purposes
of the introduction of bills and road
build amendments and enrolled bill
reports and receiving messages you're
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have
it the house is in recess
until the call of the chair
you